Yeah,
it makes me sad.
It makes me sad if you'd tell me that
you hear people saying anything bad
about Gabriel,
like he's the,
he's that guy like that.
When I think about people,
like there's a few comics that everybody
loves,
like Ron White's one of them.
If you say something bad about ron
wagon,
posting them up.
I can't talk to you.
Even agents love runway.
Like he's changed their lives.
If you start talking shit about Ron
White,
I don't have anything to say to you.
Like there's no way.
There's no way.
Unless he was really drunk.
I could see right way until this tore it
open.
Anthony.
He was like fucking 57 years old.
He got in a fistfight at some,
uh,
some bar because some woman was taking a
picture with him and the boyfriend
didn't like it.
So the boyfriend was drunk.
She came over to Ron.
Ron punched him in the face.
He now he has to have like a has to
bring a cop with him everywhere he goes.
He goes,
he brings a copy of the truck.
He told me he brings a compliment.
He's Kinda hire cops,
make sure he doesn't punch people or
they don't punch him.
He's the best God would a good dude.
I got this call from comedy central to
come down and showcase at the Irvine
Improv and I had to be spotless clean
for 10 minutes and I go down and I
really worked at it and I just pulled
away some stuff and then they called me
and they said,
you're not in it.
I'm like,
okay.
They go,
you will make the cut next year.
So I called Gabriel,
thank them.
He goes,
well,
what are you talking about?
You're not in it.
Give me five minutes.
And he calls back because you're doing
it.
You're taping it.
Okay.
So the whole time I'm thinking,
I'm doing this seven minute tv set that
they have the taping.
He pulled me over when he goes,
listen,
you call him crazy tonight.
I go,
but I've been working on this material.
He goes,
I don't give a fuck.
I want you to go crazy.
He goes,
I'm going to pay for the show.
I'm paying for it out of my pocket.
If it makes the cut,
it makes the cut or not.
It's for me.
I just wanted to me he paid for the
episode that gets shot.
That's the only got picked up for six.
They shot seven because he wanted me to
go off.
Oh Wow.
So at the end,
the whole day,
I'm thinking I'm going now.
That's sad that get down.
And he's like,
no,
you're doing fucking dirty shit.
And he goes,
I,
I planned it this way.
He goes,
I don't give a fuck what they tell you.
I want you to work this way for a
reason.
I brought it down here for a reason.
He goes,
worst case scenario,
you make the DVD,
you follow me.
Like he was like,
he fought for me to work dirty and
they've got me on comedy central.
Wow.
It's just the feeling I always get from
him.
Just he's just seems like a real good
guy.
You know?
I,
I've never heard anybody say a bad word
about Gabriel ever.
Well,
listen to this comics that know this and
you know this,
that the more you help out younger
comics,
the better it is for you.
You learn,
you look at younger guys and you learn
little things.
Sometimes I go to the comedy store,
I see a younger comics say something on
stage.
Don't hire him because of that reason.
Like I was saying,
Hey,
what are you doing next Tuesday?
You want to the Ice House and whatever.
Just because something they do,
you know,
but it's also good for you.
You did
it for us,
you helped us out.
It made you a strong economic,
you know,
anybody knows that.
Helping other guys along the way is
great.
Gabriel ride six deep.
You think you needs to ride six deep six
days before you go see Gabriel Lca,
guys.
Spanish songs and Mexican band.
Because he'll put you up.
Yeah,
he doesn't care.
That's beautiful.
You got to make a living.
Come on down.
That's beautiful.
There's not a whole lot of guys like
that that.
No,
they'd be.
They'd be suspect that you're funnier
than them,
but you're going to try this.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
come on down and what do you want to
eat?
You know,
can't worry about that or that,
but you can't.
The fund is in working with the best
guys.
The Fun,
the fun is in,
in and also seeing all these different
stages.
Like when you take a young guy on the
road with you or when you see a young
guy,
I do a really good set of the store.
You,
you recognize like those moments were
when you were young and you were just
starting to figure your material out and
you were just starting to figure out
like how to really get to the heart of
the matter quicker or what.
What's actually funny about this,
like what's clouding my judgment where I
can't figure out how to get this funny,
but occasionally these spark shine
through and you have a killer bit and
like in everybody knows like a young guy
who in the early months we'll have like
one bit when you see that bed and go,
this motherfucker's funny.
Like he's saying some shit.
Like he might not have it right now with
this motherfucker's funny.
And when you see someone who's got that,
it makes you like really aware of that
whole process,
you know,
the whole process of just getting your
legs under you as a comic and doing it
and you know,
and,
and when you're around people who are
also doing that,
like it feeds off of it,
like you could stay hungry like deepened
to your,
your career just by continuing to create
material and continuing to be around
other guys who are hungry.
And when you're doing that,
like one of the things that's going on
in our little group that is so,
it's so dynamic is that everybody is
hustling.
Everybody is doing a podcast.
Everybody's doing their standup.
Everybody's recording specials,
everybody's doing tours,
everybody's doing shit.
There's a lot going on.
And it's all new stuff.
You know,
like Ari,
he's got a new one.
He's doing an Austin if you're in
Austin,
Texas next weekend,
uh,
he's doing his special at Cap City
Comedy Club in Austin,
which is one of the best clubs on the
planet.
And I don't think it's sold out.
I think there's a little bit of tickets
left,
but probably gone soon,
but his new shit,
he's on fire.
This is.
This is the time to see him in ours.
Never been better.
He's never been better.
He's crazy.
He's crazy than the fucking.
That was beautiful.
That's why I love him because he's
correct.
I can't judge them.
I just sit there,
listen to the conversation.
I always ask them,
you walk around New York with other
teacher though,
you know it.
I gotta go is.
He genuinely doesn't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck if he.
He became like the d don't give a fuck
scale.
He became like the new metric of not
giving a fuck like they used to be
accepted.
There's levels of giving a fuck.
You know,
like you and I can't claim that we don't
give a fuck the way he does because we
have families are.
You should fear is free.
If should fear just got a vasectomy.
He would give even less of a fuck.
That would be like the last straw of
fuck that he has left in his body.
He's a barbarian.
You know what show killed me will love
it.
You know what show like fuck with me
when I did it.
Tony Hinchcliffe show on Monday nights.
The really good podcasts.
He does it.
The store,
the one where he killed Tony Killed
Tony.
Oh,
when you're watching the one minute
people go.
I went down at one night and I didn't.
It wasn't about the material.
It wasn't about anything but the look in
their eyes.
I remember that.
Look in your eye pro when you don't have
dinner in here.
Yeah,
and your car's got on me and your job
sucks and he was swinging.
I left there and I couldn't sleep that
night because I went back to 94 when I
used to go back to my room and cry or
clubs.
All of the performance.
Some they'll be good.
They'll be at the punchline.
Would write that down there.
I'm going to be there.
Yeah.
We get that San Francisco newspaper and
at the end of the,
just for laughs,
the last three pages that had a comedy
guide from Alaska all the way to Wyoming
of all the comedy club listings,
whether they will one night isn't that
and I just sit there and circle them
with a note booking through a line of
coke and cries and some day I'll be at
the fucking rusty,
you know,
but that's when I went to Tony
Hinchcliffe show.
There was,
you know what it reminded me of.
What was that movie?
What rocky movie did he take them back
to the ghetto and train them on three
when they walked in,
all the black dudes had veins in her
eyes and shit like that.
Like,
yeah,
whatever up.
I didn't give a fuck.
And he's like this memo.
All these guys rock.
This used to be you.
Yes.
This used to be.
You look at their eyes.
Rob was that.
Was that rocky three?
Was it Jamie?
Jamie is on it already.
All right,
so two,
he fights Apollo again and three he
fights buster Lang clubber clubber Lang.
I'm sorry,
was he ain't got no heart,
but you still have every night wishing
you had a real man.
Was a three.
Bring your pretty little cell phone with
my apartment tonight.
I'll show you a real man and that was at
a rock.
He couldn't take it anymore.
That was a great fucking movie,
but one we call your kids to do.
Dude.
MrT.
was one of the most terrifying fucking
villains ever in a boxing movie,
not Joe Rogan.
Do you remember the doorman challenge?
That dorm,
how he became famous?
No.
Okay.
Him,
Mr.
t him and a bunch of other dudes on NBC.
That was a show about either doorman
what bounces and they did something and
that's how he was noticed.
Something weird.
There was a show about the toughest
bounces for awhile,
six episodes,
and he was the main one.
Bounces doorman in 1980.
It was like wild world of sports type
thing.
Hey,
go back to that for a second.
Jamie to that clubber Lang footage.
The training footage.
I was under the impression that like I
remember thinking that he really looked
good as a boxer,
but I'm watching him shadow box there
and I'm like,
what?
No one has a gift.
The throwing like smoke at you.
Everybody looks good while you're
watching it.
I love that scene.
When Mickey was looking at the bubbles
and he's getting mad,
like,
Ugh,
ugh.
If you like let it go,
keep going.
It'll a show him shadow boxing,
which sometimes people don't look that
good when they're shadowboxing because
they're just trying to loosen their body
up.
There's a bunch of different like right
there that does not look that guy who
actually knows how to punch,
but you know,
it looks like a lot of swinging,
you know,
it's not.
Those aren't punches,
so like a lot of arm movements.
We've got to meet in the head cut at
that time,
it's 1980.
He didn't know what to expect.
There's a thing with was shadowboxing,
like some people think that shadowboxing
should just be a loosening up thing.
They just do it loose and they let the
shoulders go loose and they try to work
on their snap and they tried to move
around,
but then there's some people that think
you should treat it almost as if it's a
fight,
like as if you're simulating a fight.
Like Jamie looked this up,
Joseph Vault Illini shadowboxing.
He's a glory kickboxing champ and he put
up this video of how he shadow boxes and
you shadow boxes.
Like he's in a fight.
He doesn't think of it as time off or a
warm up or something like that.
What he does is he fights like a pretend
opponent.
It's pretty interesting because a lot of
guys don't do it that way.
Like not,
not to this extent like uh,
you know guys,
when you're shadow boxing,
a lot of it is just,
he kinda loosened around you doing it on
your own pace.
You're working on your own shit,
but what he does is kind of more like he
treats it like a different kind of a
workout like Justin Fortune does down at
that gym to.
Does he the second look at it as like a
calorie burner in the beginning?
Really just.
I mean if you do it correctly,
he says you should break a big sweater
or something.
Yeah,
if you do it correctly.
Which I don't know just.
Well it's a lot of people think it's
like visualization they think might be
as important as anything else.
Like everything's important.
You know,
it's important to be in shape.
It's important to be strong.
It's important to have experience in
support and to have really good
technique,
but it's also important to visualize.
There's something about carving pathways
in the brain and obviously if you're a
neuroscientist and you'll listen to
this,
you're like,
oh my God,
this idiot doesn't know what the fuck
he's talking about,
but there's,
there's something about carving
pathways.
This is not it.
There's a,
there's a different visual comedy.
You have a dream shadowboxing.
He's throwing kicks and punches and
knees and backing up and you have a.
This would stand up like you see
yourself onstage killing.
I've tried and I can't do it,
like positive realization.
No,
I don't think it works with standup.
I think um,
no,
I think uh,
with stand up the thing,
the kids doing it.
I got it.
I tried,
I took the reef of fucked me up,
but I couldn't come to focus.
Like the visualizations.
Yeah.
Like I couldn't see myself onstage like
walking out and seeing people go.
I could see myself coming out of the
garden.
I can't do that shit.
Here's just for me personally,
here's why I would try,
I would try not to think like that
because if I have,
I visualize myself doing something and
doing it really well.
I would,
um,
I would think of,
I wouldn't think of the thing I was
doing anymore.
Now I'm thinking of like the accolades
or the position it is or look you're on
a big stage and look,
you know,
you're at this place and you're at
Massey Hall in Toronto or something,
you know,
some historic venue like,
and then one day I was there like,
that seems like you're thinking more
about,
about success than what,
what success really is,
is like if you're doing something and
you try to do it,
do it the best you can.
Not the or the reaction that it gets,
so if I'm concentrating on the reaction,
like I'm concentrating on going up there
and killing,
I would have to be visualizing doing a
show,
so I'd have to begin realizing people
laughing.
I can't.
I've tried,
I can't do it.
I've sat there like at the gym and put
right to cool off and he said,
well maybe I'll see myself killing for
the special or whatever.
I didn't see any of that shit.
Doesn't that make sense though?
That if you think of yourself as killing
you thinking of other people laughing,
but you're not thinking about yourself
then.
Right?
Like so if you're visualizing skiing,
you're thinking about skiing,
right?
You're thinking about tucking.
You're thinking about doing your moves
in the correct way.
You get the most amount of speed and the
most amount of controls.
You're headed down this hill,
right?
You're not thinking about other people.
You're not thinking about other people's
response to each one of those things you
do.
Like if every time he did a curve and
you didn't get a laugh,
he'd be like,
what the fuck?
I thought it was skiing good.
You know,
if you tell a joke,
well you get a laugh,
right?
But you don't want to think about that
laugh.
You don't want to visualize a laugh.
You want to pretend that people are
laughing at it.
You want to actually find out what's
funny and have other people tell you for
you,
like you kind of know,
but you don't really know until you do
it in front of them.
Right.
So to visualize that is really weird
because you're visualizing two different
mindsets so you're not in this the zone
of actually being there.
You're,
you're visualizing artificial laughter.
I mean,
I guess you could visualize this state
that you're feeling when you're killing,
when you're really relaxed on stage and
you're having a good time and
everything's fun.
I could visualize that state.
That makes sense.
I can't,
but I think even that state,
you could only like visualize it and I
shouldn't say only.
Maybe I could only do it in chunks.
I think I just think it's better to just
concentrate on just doing.
It just never worked for me.
So I wonder if you ever did up.
I on it.
I just,
I also think would stand up like you
could do a lot of sets and stuff,
but I don't know if he should
concentrate on it as much as
concentrating on just life itself and
finding things that you think are funny
and interesting.
You know,
because sometimes if you concentrate
just on standup too much,
you almost like narrows your focus.
So you're thinking so much about
standup.
You're not thinking about shit to talk
about onstage because you're not really
thinking about it.
You're,
you're,
you're obsessed with some tour date
details or some,
you know,
some thing that might be an offer that's
on the table.
What do you think I should do it?
Instead of thinking about that kind of
Shit,
you just like,
you only have a certain amount of
resources that your brain has available
and it's when you can stop thinking
about like if you can just push any
career ideas completely out of your head
and just exist as a person and then go
and do stuff.
If you could figure out how to shut that
off and go and do stuff,
for me at least it gives me more ideas.
I get more ideas that way and I get A.
I'm.
I feed my curiosity too quick.
It feels like a feed.
My curiosity and an honest way.
Instead of thinking about religious
reading,
things that I would think would be funny
on stage or read and stuff that I think
would be fun to talk about in a podcast.
I just look at Shit.
That's interesting.
You know?
Goddamn.
It makes sense on a one to 10 right now
we're cooking.
It's up there like I've stolen this
morning.
I stopped at the weed store on the way
up in a little half.
I had a bull to get the party started my
system.
You know what I'm saying?
We're about a month away from legal
weed.
That's it,
but it's going to go down for people
like me because the edible count is
going down to 10 milligrams.
I already got the warning of that.
There will be meetings.
That guy goes for you to 900 milligrams.
Again,
you'll have to be floated.
You'll be fucking stuffed with gelatin.
That 10 milligrams.
Just stop this.
Yeah,
no,
there's some shit going around that.
I'm also doing that cbd to one to one.
That's good too.
Oh,
not bad at night.
This goddamn Jambo breath spray this.
This one milligram does madison from God
a.
This one's a thousand of what?
A spray bottle.
The whole bottles of thousand.
So if you're to take the top off that
shit.
That's really good.
That's a bit open to that.
I take the cbd off from a company in
Denver.
XNL.
It's a 300 milligram c deal.
When he got back
from Jujitsu,
he put it right onto here.
It doesn't get you out.
This is the woman that just by the time
you get out of the shower,
you're like,
what happened?
Oh,
who has seen?
So it's just cbd oil because they,
you know,
they make it with marijuana dermally.
Well that goes back.
That goes into your system lot better.
The one that one that I'm taking this
for children.
People don't want thc in it,
but this one has such a high conscious
trade of CBD oil.
Yeah,
but the other thing,
they make it with something else.
Oh,
that he goes,
put that on the tunnel.
One or two drops.
You're a big guy,
right?
When you get home from Jujitsu and then
take a shower.
Not too bad.
Joe Rogan.
Let's try this stuff here.
Stuff of it.
Some of it tastes like Dick.
Some of it tastes like fucking guava
juice.
Does.
These people that do require the Jews?
Jesus Christ.
My bad mentor,
my mentee is actually a nice little
breast spray.
Another two shots.
The GL fucked up and did too many
sprays.
One of these ones before Sam Harris'
podcast and Sam was talking crazy shit
about artificial intelligence and all
this other,
you know,
every time I talked to that guy,
he's a neuroscientist.
Very,
very so I know.
Yeah.
I know.
You know is right and I was.
I was barbecued when I was talking to
him.
Like barbecued.
I totally overestimated or
underestimated.
These sprays had no idea like I thought
like a couple pumps is probably like a
pot lollipop,
you know?
Now,
I don't know.
It must have been hundreds of milligrams
each day.
Anything under your fucking tongue like
that?
Yeah.
It goes quick.
Sixty seconds.
You're on a plane.
Next scene.
The planes fucking making weird noises.
That lighting on fire and now it was.
Androids are hitting them.
It's going to change the world when it
becomes legal folks and it's not going
to change the world for the worst.
It's going to change it for the better.
It's gonna.
Make people paranoid as fuck.
It's going to make people nicer.
Really.
Is that paranoid as fuck thing?
That's good.
You don't say Dick Do.
That's how I live.
I don't say Dick.
I don't know.
No blame.
There's some days I don't even fucking
shave.
I leave the house and they don't know.
It's tremendous to live that way.
I don't bother nobody.
I go into starbucks.
I don't hear nothing.
I don't know.
Nothing.
Time for reflection.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
One thing,
I don't get hives when I go to the
Jigsaw,
I still can't work that up yet.
That's too real phone call Joey.
That's too real for me.
Somebody gets me the deep south.
I'm fucking history.
Used to get high before I fuck you guys
do the eye candy and I used to take
giant bong hits,
giant bomb and then we would roll.
Yeah,
I'd have a panic attack.
Yeah.
We would go into class and as soon as
somebody gets on top of you like that
and he would teach like that,
he would teach like that.
Blitzkrieg teach like a,
like a Jedi Knight.
Yeah.
He teach tremendous master how you want
your fucking dude unconscious.
Well,
for him,
for his style
of the key.
He's like,
um,
you know,
Eddie,
he's got a very interesting style,
not just of Jujitsu but of explaining
his Jujitsu,
you know,
explaining all the moves and all the
different positions and it's like a,
there's a,
there's like a presentation that he's
doing.
It's like a,
it's like an art form.
We pay.
Somebody brought me a comedian friends.
He's doing something completely
different.
On the other side,
because every place you show up to do
comedy is one fucking do it with a 10
plan is at least he's got a little any
of these three for people because even
the little towns,
they get the videos and get a mat and
they do all that shit by themselves
watching a fucking videos.
They've told me when I went to Omaha,
people came in from our ma.
There's a 10th planet Endo Model.
That's great,
but people who don't want to make.
The people were telling me they get like
couches,
Jujitsu couches,
mattress.
That's like they're fucking grassy.
So if your little town doesn't have an
eddie spreading and now like his
students are winning fucking tournament
and now Ebi is on Tbi is game the best
thing to ever happen to submission
grappling because it made it exciting.
They figured out a way to about rules
and you know that right?
But when I'm reading Hugh Jitsu magazine
and this saying that they're gonna take,
they're gonna start using Ebi rules and
shit.
Ebi Is Eddie Bravo exhibit.
Yeah.
You know,
Chael Sonnen did it and here's how
beautiful Eddie is.
Eddie doesn't even want money for them
using it.
I'm pretty sure he was like,
yeah,
I just want those rules to be
established as the best rules.
Just give me credit called the Ebi rules
and you can use some smart way to do it.
He just wants to spread Jujitsu in the
right way and you know,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with having a non tbi rules of any
either.
You know,
like if somebody wants to do like what
metamorris was doing and have these long
bouts and if they go to draw at the end
to go to draw at the end,
you know,
a lot on the podcast,
some of the time you got to break
everything down and be like just I bbs
and well there's anybody.
So essentially anybody can essentially
start their own rules like Abu Dhabi
where uh,
Eddie choked out heuler they had a very
interesting rules where the first period
of the fight there was no points and
then encouraged you to go for it.
Right?
So you try to submit someone within the
first,
uh,
first half of the fight or take it real
conservative,
which was another approach,
and you play super defense for the first
half of the fight.
Then at the second half of the fight you
can score points.
So you score points for take downs,
score points for guard,
passes,
near submissions,
things like that.
So I think their,
their logic was that if they just have
no points in the beginning,
it doesn't matter if a dude mounts you,
doesn't matter if a guy takes your back,
if you defend,
if you're trying to attack him and go
after him,
sometimes you'd worried if I don't get
this guy might be so far behind it
points I'll never catch up.
Like if you just go for it and you fuck
up and you wind up in a bad position,
then you defend that position and then
you get back to your feet and then maybe
the guy takes you down.
That's a sequence of events that if
you're counting takedowns and near
submissions and things like that can put
you in his giant deficit.
And if the guys that good that he could
do that to you,
maybe you underestimated them and you'll
never catch up to them,
but you could find out if you just go
for it,
if you both go for it and you don't
worry about points.
So that was their idea I think.
I think to promote more excitement so
people just go for it in the beginning.
And then the idea about the second half
is that once you're establishing who's
the better grappler,
when two guys roll and they're trying to
kill each other,
you learn pretty quick who's better.
And so then if no one's better,
if it's just by a very,
very,
very slight edge.
So if you've gotten to the second half
of the fight and you both,
you're both in a neutral position but
you both attacked,
both defended and no one's had any sort
of an upper hand.
Those last few minutes is,
it's really going to count because
that's the few minutes where your
determination in training camp showed
up.
Your ability to adjust,
your ability to overcome.
Like all those things really do
determine who's best.
So having that towards the end of the
fight.
That makes sense.
How long has Abu Dhabi,
if I go to the whole man,
that's a good question because at 2:15
says the two times I'm a don't remember,
I'm thinking it's two tens,
but that seems like a long time.
Maybe it was less than that.
Um,
Abo dobby submission,
grappling time limits.
Because what does Eddie doing with Ebi?
He does the first.
How many minutes?
I'm not sure.
I think it's like the first nine minutes
or something like that.
They just go at it and there's no
points.
And if some,
if they make it into the final or they
make it a pass at time limit,
then they go through these series of bad
positions.
Like one guy starts on the other guy's
back and he has over under and then go,
ready,
go.
And you start from there.
So one guy has got your back and you
have to defend it.
And if you can tap him then he has an
opportunity to try the same position.
And if you could tap you,
I think it goes to who?
God who.
First I think it like it's in the amount
of time it took to tap them,
so that's where the competition would be
five minutes over time.
So qualifying rounds,
six minutes,
three minutes overtime if there's a draw
finals,
eight minutes,
four minutes over time if there's a draw
with no advantage.
So what it probably is like four minutes
in.
They start scoring the point.
Yeah,
there it is right there at the first
four minutes are without positive
points,
but negative points start from the
beginning of the fight until the end.
And I think negative points or like when
you draw guard,
when you pull guard,
I think that was a negative point.
I don't know if it still is,
but I think that's silly because some
guys,
if they pull you into their guard,
you're fucked.
Like there's guys like vinny malaise
lace or like,
um,
a Shinya Aoki.
That guy is just nasty fucking guard.
If in his guard you're in a terrible
place,
the church is sponsoring vinny magalogs
a magalog is a bad mother.
I love his Jujitsu.
So fucking high level man.
You know,
he's,
he spent a lot of time fighting in MMA
and because of the fighting in the mma,
I think a lot of people slept on his
Jujitsu.
They forget what a fiend ami is.
He Flying Armbar,
paid the Pano,
who's like this multiple time Brazilian
jujitsu world champion and vinny.
Vinny Magalhaes hit him with a flying
arm bar.
Do you know that's,
that is like pulling your deck out and
slapping it across a world champions
face.
I mean literally how,
how powerful that move.
But when you say flying,
check this out,
see if you could find it.
He's huge.
Two,
usually 230 pounds and he hits him with
a flying arm bar and it's perfect.
She was perfect.
Like there's no,
there's no defending.
Now this guy that he's.
This is uh,
this is Chris Weidman.
He got Chris Weidman with it too.
Yeah.
Well you could watch this to.
I mean Vinnie did hit Chris Weidman with
the same shit.
Dude.
Vinnie's super worldclass.
Now you gotta remember Chris Weidman a
two time NCAA all American wrestler like
super fucking grappler.
And that's how good Vinnie Meg Alexis.
I mean,
Weidman,
when he won the UFC,
let's see if you could find it in here
because this is a long match.
Weidman,
when he,
uh,
when he won the UFC middleweight title
from Anderson Silva was widely thought
to be like one of the toughest best
wrestlers,
best grapplers it's ever fought in the
middleweight division.
There was a big strength of his,
is that he was just so nasty on the
ground and so fucking strong.
Oh my God.
Exactly.
You see when a dude can do that to a
Chris Weidman,
that's what a bad motherfucker.
Vinny Magalhaes says,
you just don't.
That doesn't happen.
Watch this again.
Come on,
son.
I mean he just took that with just
spectacular technique and he's a huge
guy.
I,
he will say he's at least,
you know what to 10 or something like
that to 15,
I don't know.
In the UFC he fought a light
heavyweight.
Right?
Go find.
Yeah,
because you've lost a Ryan Bader and the
finals member of the ultimate fighter.
She's striking.
You know,
he got better at striking,
but that was what had held him back.
His Jujitsu is off the fucking chain.
He did another stint in the UFC.
Right.
Me Do a couple stents.
Yeah,
but like you get caught in that guy's
guard,
you're fucked.
Like that's a bad position.
So I disagree with them.
Like saying that pulling guard is a one
point disadvantage.
So if he pulls a gun out on me,
really mega lez urine health,
urine,
hell no,
like get out of it.
But you're in danger.
You're in severe danger.
There's people where their guard is more
of a defensive position as people with
who the wrap their legs around you and
what they're trying to do is just kind
of hold on me to just breathe.
Yeah.
Maybe they're taking their sweet time.
They're get to breathe,
they're gonna relax and then they're
gonna.
Maybe try to explode back up to their
feet or try to reverse your.
Try to stand up or something like that.
But then there's guys like vinny,
they're trying to break your arm and
that's immediately what it's going to go
to.
It was going to go to rubber guard.
I mean,
Vinnie has like really fucking
ridiculous experience when it comes to
submissions.
I mean he's just super technical and a
big guy like that's a rare combination.
If you get caught in that guy's guard,
you're,
you know,
you're not favored to get out of it.
Especially if you underestimated it.
Like that's another thing about guards,
if you train with a guy,
it was like an Eddie Bravo or his guards
just all ultra dangerous.
If you don't train with a guy like that,
maybe the guys in your gym,
they're not scary from their back so you
don't worry about it.
Maybe you're a wrestler,
maybe you got good defense,
you feel like,
you know what,
I see that shit come and nobody gets me
in my gym,
but they probably don't have the same
level of guard.
There's some guys out there that have
this ridiculously reflect refined level
of God.
You remember Paul Sas?
No.
So the guy in the UFC,
he won almost every fight.
I think he won one by.
He'll hook.
He,
he,
he'll hooked.
Michael Johnson who is going to be
fighting.
Habib never gotten that off.
But Paul Sas Triangle the fuck out of
everybody.
I mean he triangled the fuck out of
Nobody can get away from his triangle.
It was just this crazy thing.
If this kid would grab a ahold,
we'd pull guard.
He would get his creep,
his legs up over your shoulder.
And before you know it,
you were choking herself to sleep.
She was incredible.
He,
I don't remember how many fights he won
by triangle,
but it was so ridiculous because
everybody knew it and he would go out
there and he would do it and everybody's
like,
just stay the fuck away from his
triangle.
Just stay the fuck away from his
Next thing you know,
he's on his back and you're like,
it's a terrible position to be in.
And if a guy's legs are like really good
at doing those movements,
your legs are so strong.
There's so much stronger than your arms.
The thing that we lack is not strength.
It's dexterity.
Well,
some guys figured that dexterity thing
out and when you have these high level
guys,
you'll see if you.
That's just a.
That was one where he won by leg lock
here.
But look how good he is dude.
Like when he,
when he gets guys into a position where
they think that they're safe,
it's all it is,
is another leg lock to look at that.
Oh this is nasty shit man.
But,
so this is my point is that like there
are guys that are super,
super dangerous off their back.
It shouldn't be a negative point.
Michael.
Jonathan has nothing on.
Has not thrown a punch.
So even if you mess with him.
Yeah,
he got tore up here.
I mean this is a bad because if they get
rid of Paul says they get videos,
economy think.
So I don't remember.
I mean he didn't win all of his fights.
He was a tough,
tough guy.
But man,
his submissions were awesome to watch
and he fucked a lot of guys up off his
back another.
And this is an mma whereas actually,
oh damn,
that's nasty.
And they tapped right there.
And this is an mma where you can get
punched in Abu Dhabi,
you can't even get punched so you can
get much deeper in a position to not
worrying about worrying about being
vulnerable to strikes.
So guys like Gary Tonin was like one of
the best in the world right now.
He's,
I'm known for his leg locks and he takes
off his back all the time.
So to think that that guy gets a
negative point because he's attacking
off of his back to me.
So that's loony as loony.
If he gets a hold of you and you're in
his guard,
you're going to get your knee ripped
apart.
If guys at a knee ripper,
I mean they're all the Donna,
her death squad,
that's what they call themselves.
You know John Donahoe Dude,
he's got like a hundred knee rippers
over there.
Just get super technical leg lock guys
were there and they're all doing it
primarily off their back.
But in MMA it's way more dangerous in
MMA.
Guys can punch you.
Oh wait,
no.
That Fried Shit I've told you once I
told you you given makes me nervous.
It gives me anxiety.
Are you one of those guys that shows up
for Jujitsu class for wrestling shoes
on?
No,
there's always a guy like that.
No.
There is a guy at my place and you don't
want to fuck with them or say something
about his restaurant.
He don't speak the language.
He's like from Bulgaria.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
One minute.
You're in this garden,
next one that you're swinging around
the.
Yeah,
and the Sambo Guy.
I'm 100 to 100 pounds heavier dude.
Those guys are terrifying.
Like the first day he came in to visit
and all you heard was Ba,
ba Ba boom.
Yeah.
He didn't really know.
Like he just.
Just a great guy.
Yeah.
He thought he was still in the fucking
Kamala over there.
Well,
he was probably great guys.
Great guys.
Just buddies.
A Blue Bell always take the time to
teach me something.
Great guys.
I mean it,
but he just has the strength of dead
fucking skinny guys from Russia,
whatever those little,
those little neighborhoods can be.
Those motherfuckers been,
you know,
they don't pick up weights.
They pick up trees and shit like that.
And they know how to handle off balance
and stuff.
It's a really beautiful thing to see.
I want to.
I stayed one day afterwards as I was
getting dressed and he was teaching like
the higher balance,
like they were flying.
Yeah.
Sambo guys especially,
uh,
there's,
you know,
there's two types of.
There's combat sambo,
which is like would fade or used to
fight in.
You ever see that where they put
headgear on and they have like a judo,
Jackson mma gloves and they beat the
fuck out of each other.
Dude,
that's a,
that's one kind of sambal that's more of
a,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of a hybrid.
It's almost like they have the juno
jacket.
They were fucking judo jack and shorts
on the,
um,
the guy has the world series of fighting
heavyweight champion.
I forget his name,
but he's a Russian gentleman and he's a
guy who is that his name?
It got.
But he's,
he's the first guy to beat fader in a
long time.
He beat him in combat.
Sambo before fate or a wind up losing an
MMA.
Yeah.
I vanoff blog,
a blog boy Ivan off blog,
avant off is it tough,
tough fucking guy.
But he beat fade or in that combat sambo
stuff where they had the judo jacket on
shit,
and I think it was before fate or was
went on that losing streak.
Now combat is.
Well,
obviously you show up with fucking
swords and shit.
No,
no,
they just,
it's just mma.
It's MMA with a judo jacket on.
Now.
What color?
Peach.
That's a good question.
What does Chris Herzog is big time
sambo?
This guy comes over and does seminars in
rockchester.
I would have to bad or the other.
I don't know.
I don't.
I mean,
I'm sure there's a bunch of.
I mean I'm not,
I'm not that well versed in,
in Zombot,
but there's two different styles.
Assembling.
A lot of times people confuse the two of
them.
Like,
um,
one time I was watching a fight and they
were talking about this guy's a sambo
background and the commentator was
saying that he didn't think that in
sambo there were strikes,
so probably won't be as comfortable with
getting hit because he's a sambo guy,
but he,
but he didn't realize is he actually
came from that combat sambo background,
which is the fate or background,
which is where they would have these
fights.
Were you ever seen it see,
pull up combat sambo because it's kind
of wild.
It's weird looking like it's high level
MMA,
but they have judo jackets on and
headgear and they're kicking the shit
out of each other,
punching the shit out of each other.
I mean,
it is mma,
but there's also grappling to.
And they're aided by the,
the,
the thing.
Yeah.
I mean this is a,
is weird looking,
right?
They got a fucking jacket on and they're
doing mma.
I,
it doesn't totally make sense.
No cage,
you know,
look at that.
Oh shit son.
Oh my God.
That was a three 62.
Yeah.
So you know,
that's.
Yeah,
no cage.
I like a lot.
I've been saying this lately,
I think this is stupid.
I think cages are stupid.
I think if we have a floor that's big
enough to have a basketball game,
you have a floor that's big enough for
two days to fight.
Fuck,
come on.
You put down some mats.
No more walls.
This pushing each other up against the
wall is stupid.
Unless you're fighting some hallway.
Why are you fighting all go outside out
in the woods.
You crazy kids.
They did in Russia,
man.
They had a fucking a MMA fight on a
football field.
But what the fuck were you talking about
and the way in today,
you would drop some knowledge on me
about some gym where they're fighting in
the fucking movie with the black dudes.
What's that movie that the kid came on?
He.
Billy Corbin did.
Oh,
dogfight.
Yeah.
Then when we told them about dog
fighting,
and you're talking about some gentleman,
you said you'd save it for the podcast.
This is what I was telling you.
Like,
do you know what happened with conor
Mcgregor and Nate Diaz with a bottle?
They threw water bottles,
plastic water bottles.
Uh,
they got,
someone might've thrown a monster
energy,
can someone throw a can see if it can
hit you or someone you care about that
would suck the water bottles,
like come on.
Anyway,
they got fined a $150,000
and it should definitely shouldn't
fucking throw water bottles.
Right.
So part of me is like,
well if they get discouraged throwing
water bottles,
that shit stupid.
Right?
But,
but did the altercation,
the altercations probably good for
business.
The altercation.
I mean I get excited.
I see Nate Diaz and conor mcgregor
screaming at each other cry and it'll
fuck you.
No fuck you.
Fuck.
You can get crazy with each other.
It makes you excited.
And I think that generates a pay per
view buys.
I don't think conor stupid.
I don't think nate stupid.
I think they're smart.
I think they know what they're doing
when it comes to that kind of stuff.
So that's a part of the show.
I mean,
did he really think he was gonna hit him
with that water bottle?
You know,
fucking Nate Diaz.
It's hard to hit him with a punch.
How the fuck are you going to hit him
with a water bottle that's coming from
300 feet away?
He's not going to see that.
He's not going to move out of the way of
that water bottle,
you know?
I mean what they decide to get upset
about and what they don't decide to get
upset about is what's weird about
athletic commissions.
You know,
like one of the things they were talking
about whether or not they were going to
test nate for his vape pen because he
had a cbd vape pen,
which is cbd,
not even,
not even psychoactive.
It doesn't make you high,
but it does alleviate some inflammation
and it provides people that have like
back pain or something like that or
especially after a long fight provides
you with a little relief.
But what's crazy is the only reason why
they would want you to not do it.
Obviously it's not performance
enhancing.
You're not performing anymore.
The performance is over.
So are they protecting you from
yourself?
Like what are they doing?
They,
they,
they don't want you to do it because
you're flaunting the fact that you're
doing it in front of everybody.
They piss him after the CBD.
We'll just through smoking that.
I think he had already done his post
fight thing.
I think you'd do that before you do the
press conference.
I think.
I don't know though.
It's a good question.
I'm not entirely sure and they might do
it different way differently in
different places,
but either way you're not concerned
about him.
Like what do you,
what's the issue?
Like what is the issue?
It's just,
it looks bad.
Does it look bad that he's that vapors
coming out?
He's scared of dragons.
Let's see.
Bdo business went the roof then.
I'm sure it did and it should and it
should room and wait,
wait until it becomes illegal.
We're a month away.
When it becomes legal then it's really
going to go nuts.
It's going to be good for everybody,
but anyway,
so they get fucking pissed at him for
that.
But the,
the connor the fine was so high.
I'm like a hundred and $50,000.
Wow.
Well,
you said he made $40 million.
Next time shut your mouth.
They won't fucking know.
That's true.
100.
You know,
even the other kid made to three mil,
half of that after taxes.
One point five on 50.
Don't really put a dent in your fucking
thing.
Next time you won't throw fucking
bottles.
That is.
You've got less state bowling unless
they both went to Dana.
So listen,
this jacked up the things we like to see
it.
We want them to use.
Pick up the tab for them.
$300 because it came out of your fucking
and for the paper views something.
There's always 1:50
is not that bad.
They walked away with a ton of loot.
It's a good point.
It's got to be some type of
repercussion.
One 50 and they can fight again in
November.
Right?
Listen,
I got to court without a license.
10,
15 years ago in la.
First time ever I was talking on the
phone like I pulled over.
He goes,
where's your license?
It didn't work that day I went down to
La County.
I stepped in front of a judge by BIPAP.
The guy looked at me straight in the
face.
She goes,
you could pay 200 and come back with
your license will give me 50 and I don't
want to see you again.
What do you think I did?
I gave him $200.
Game Five,
5:50
and in time I got my license.
Not with a gun to my head.
Yeah.
Sometimes you pay a little extra that
let you fight in November.
Now you earn next time and now you could
make up that 1:50.
You're earning at least they're not
suspended for a year.
Yeah,
that's true.
Here's,
here's my thought,
but I don't think 150 is bad.
If you've got a good charity for it.
The center of the charity.
Yeah.
Instead of going to an athletic
department,
what?
I mean,
I'm sure the athletic department
department somewhere that'd be a girl's
soccer team or something like that for
that day.
I know that that's like a good thing,
right,
but 300,000
into their pocket is what pisses you
off.
What they decide to get mad at.
And what they don't decide to get mad
at,
because this is the thing that I found.
Do you know,
did you watch when Floyd Day,
whether it was doing,
I believe it was for showtime,
they were doing one of those behind the
scenes things at his gym and he has what
he calls doghouse fights and I just let
me just say that this kind of thing has
been going on in Jim's forever,
right?
They've always had gym wars and people
have even set up and this was a thing
that I'm pretty sure it became illegal
in California fairly recently.
Within the last decade.
They stopped allowing people to have
what they call smokers and what a smoker
is.
They have organized fights,
but there's not really like a lot of
medical on hand only gets paid.
Nobody gets paid paid.
But it gives people valuable experience.
So used to have a lot of them in Muay
Thai.
Like I used to go to them.
They were cool.
They would set up these little plastic
lawn chairs.
You'd pay a small amount of money,
you know,
like 30 bucks or something like that.
And you go and you watch all these
amateur fights and a lot of times kids
are pretty fucking talented and it's fun
to watch.
But so always had organized jim fights.
So essentially what floyd mayweather did
was have his own,
like in house Jim fights like amateur
fights.
Like they didn't even disguise the fact
that it was a competition.
Like they weren't trying to,
uh,
they weren't trying to spar.
Like these guys are having fights and
he's,
he was talking about how it's to the
death.
It's really crazy.
And he has these guys.
One guy gets beat up and he's hocked
seem rock bonds brother or son Seen
Rockmont son I believe.
See if you could see if you can google
who the gentleman was.
Comments are saying it was his brother,
but his brother,
maybe it's his brother.
That makes more sense because how seem
Rockmont is not that old to have a kid
that's,
that,
you know,
like,
that developed because he looks like
he's like in his twenties maybe is.
Anyway,
point being so this English guy beats
up,
seen brock bonds,
one brother,
and then the mom comes back with the
bigger brother and the English guy
fights him to all on the same day and
they're fighting like these 30 minute
rounds just gets crazy
because during a winter and they put it
on TV.
Yeah,
I mean dude,
if there's definitely.
And sorry,
the question was,
is that Jesus?
No,
I don't think there is.
I mean there might be,
I mean floyd might reward them or
something like that,
but I mean it's,
it's crazy shit and I mean in one way,
yeah,
this will develop,
develop character and I don't have a
problem with people doing whatever they
decide to do.
If somebody wants to fight a 30 minute
fight,
I don't have a problem with that.
You should be able to do it if you want
to.
They've been doing this.
Jesus love Chicago,
but the thing is some Boston when he was
a brown belt Galley with your buddy
issue that this.
But um,
but the thing is I'm not a promoter in
Las Vegas,
right?
That's a big difference.
That's a big difference and I'm not a
professional fighter on television.
I'm not,
I'm,
you know,
and I'm not necessarily saying there's
anything wrong with what he did because
it is a part of gym culture.
It is a part of what's made champions.
I mean this kind of stuff,
these,
this heat,
these heated battles.
This is a very uncomfortable reality
that elite fighters like floyd
mayweather face like to be that good,
you have to be that real.
And for a guy like him to show like
these kind of crazy 30 minute,
no time limit fights in the gym and put
it on tv,
it's pretty wild.
It's in and I see both sides of it.
I totally see floyd made with a side of
it.
Look at him.
He feeds off that,
but guess what?
That mentality is why that motherfucker
was $49.
Zero,
right?
That mother,
arguably the best boxer ever,
who,
who got hurt less than floyd mayweather,
who box people's face off that everybody
thought it was going to kill him better
than floyd mayweather.
When he fought my Donna and he found him
the first time and my daughter caught
him in one of the exchanges,
like right before the bell rang and we
were like,
whoa.
And then they fought again the second
time and he just put a clinic on my
Donna just put a clinic on him.
It was like,
all of a sudden my donald was fighting a
totally different guy,
like floyd had figured out my style or
decided not to fuck around this fight
and decided to really take him seriously
and really focus on him.
And he just beat his ass brother.
Different things.
A lot of ways I agree with a lot of this
shitty does,
you know?
But uh,
listening to him,
his emotion games off the charts,
off the charts,
he's self promotion games the greatest
of all time.
He's making me more money.
He's made me laugh at night sometimes.
I've watched this show and he's made me
laugh and it said,
show you watch because you don't really
like the dude.
I mean,
he,
you know,
so I know that I would love him.
I bet I love it.
I would love him.
He's a psycho and I wanted to fight like
three times.
I'm like,
you know what?
The proof is in the motherfucking
putting.
Exactly.
That's it.
Exactly is in the pudding.
Let them do whatever the fuck he wants.
You don't.
You don't get a guy like that unless
he's a guy like that.
You don't get that $49 unless he's that
kind of dude,
but I think he handles it as good as any
fucking human being that could be in
that position.
Handles it.
It's a crazy position to be in,
to be a young guy and be worth that much
money.
And you're known your nicknames.
Money.
Mayweather.
I mean what the fuck?
Names himself.
Money.
He's hilarious.
I ain't got nothing wrong with you.
If you talk shit and back at any point.
Well,
if you know what I'm reading right now,
a buddy of mine gave it to me.
Hollywood hadn't listened to you old
enough for that.
Hollywood had this.
There was a dallas cowboy.
That was the real deal.
You understand me?
They don't even make them like that.
No more showed up rookie day.
I'll give you the article with three
hits of acid,
a gram of blow right here,
the thousand dollars in the off season.
He would rent the hotel and hanging out
with prior at the comedy store while he
would have the one was the lab would
point the sisters.
This was before Rick James and before
they played the Denver Broncos in this
claim to fame,
he went on national TV and took care of
the orange crush with the Denver
Broncos,
drink that soda and he fucking crushed
it with the juice in one hand and the
super bowl.
He intercepted in score.
There's online,
back and they just fucking blow up the
ball with big fucking,
you know,
he talks shit.
People,
hey,
hey.
He talks shit on Game Day.
He showed up and they threw him out
because he put fucking two fingers up
during the game and the owner of the
cowboys.
So um,
at that time,
what's two fingers,
you can do two things.
They will lose on TV,
national TV and Hollywood Henderson.
The camera came over.
Instead of watching,
he advertised the towel goes,
Yo,
if you need these tiles.
And then we'll like to receive his
company
the next day.
Tom Landry Fine Hollywood Henderson.
And after that it was all over.
He was smoking crack and Bazookas.
But he won the lottery in Texas.
He was a liar.
He became a born again Christian.
Oh my goodness.
Oh motherfucker dog.
Wow.
That's a fun story.
Yeah man.
I just want to be clear about all that
stuff that I was saying about the floyd
mayweather thing.
I just think that the athletic
commissions,
you know,
like when they find people and when they
get mad at people for stuff,
it's sometimes they do it in a very
heavy handed way.
And I think it's kind of obscene.
Like what happened with vandelay Silva I
think is obscene.
You know that story,
they banned vandelay for life.
He,
he ran away from a test,
which he definitely shouldn't have done,
definitely shouldn't have done.
But if he was on something,
they shouldn't have been on.
Suspend him as if you caught them for
that.
Something like suspend him for,
you know,
maybe an extra six months because he's a
dick because he ran away from you.
But you can't save for life.
He can't just take away.
It was,
it wasn't that isolated incident only
vandelay.
Who was it the old way?
Isolated incident.
Yeah.
Vandelay wasn't as positive before.
No.
Vandelay has never tested positive for
ever know that.
I mean it's not saying he hasn't done
anything like in,
in pride,
you know,
ensign.
Anyway,
when he's on here,
he was talking about his pride contract
and he said it was and Eve Edwards at
the same thing.
It said in capital letters we do not
test first steroids.
They give you a syringe on the house and
Shit.
Yeah.
So I mean it's not saying that he didn't
do them ever,
but he never.
Vandelay never tested positive.
No.
So they had no reason to suspect him
other than,
you know,
if you follow the sniff test,
but you got no.
There was no proof.
I mean,
and again that's the only argument,
whether it's proof or not per se,
it's not whether or not you think he was
guilty.
I would say something.
I thought I had a like good stories
about hiding from probation officers and
shit.
This is.
Oh,
this is.
This is actual instance contract at the
bottom there.
Oh,
here it says performance enhancing
stimulants of steroid based family are
specifically excluded from the scope of
the test.
Why don't they just right have at it
boys and gals to and so I hit
everybody's one probation over some
bolder that used to fuck with me so I
had to hide from him from time to time,
but I've heard some stories.
He is after about some of the Brazilian
fighters in Shit.
What they've done with us goes down
there,
whatever the fuck it is,
didn't Jose?
I will stop them at the airport.
Something happened where they got their
fucking visas return.
The something like that.
The Brazilians have a Tory is for
fucking with these people.
Fucking with them.
Something that happened,
they were at the airport has got the
gun.
That was somebody else who had a
problem.
Well the guy came to all those gym and
they didn't know who the guy was and
they didn't trust them.
And you got to also,
I mean all suspicions decided that
people always have,
when someone comes to you and says
they're going to test you for steroids
and then you don't want to take that
test,
there's always gonna be suspicion,
but that's because you're guilty,
but you have to take into consideration
the possibility that it was not
communicated very well,
that you might be talking about two
different languages and although who
speaks a little bit of English but not
that much,
all of a sudden these meeting these
people and he's in Brazil and he's very
famous so he doesn't know if he's being
fucked with.
He didn't know this is real.
If it's random,
if they just show up,
nobody warns you.
So it's not like the UFC calls you up
and says,
Joseph,
how are you man?
It's Mike from the UFC.
I just want to let you know that this
guy who was testing you right now for
steroids is totally legit.
No,
they just show up,
dude.
They just show up and they don't even
want to present you with information.
They don't want to present you with id
like Chael Sonnen was telling a story
about how when they tested him and how
bizarre it was.
Then they say they pulled them into a
bathroom or something like that to test
him.
Yeah,
like a,
a janitor's closet or something.
They tested them in a janitor's closet
and he's like,
what the fuck?
You're drawing my blood.
And he's like,
it turned out to actually be Usada.
He goes,
but it could easily have been just some
fucking crazy person who just wanted my
blood and my piss,
you know?
I mean,
you don't know.
It's not what happened with Tim Kennedy.
What happened with him?
That they went over to his house and he
came home from the gym.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And the guy made him take a shower.
I don't know how to read the whole
thing.
They couldn't do the test for like an
hour for some reason.
I don't know.
I don't remember what the reason was.
Or maybe the guy had to get the test
brought over or something and the guy
goes,
I have to keep an eye on it.
He goes,
really well,
listen.
He goes,
I might take a shower.
I just got done training and that's
actually if you.
Especially if you're doing Jujitsu,
it's actually really important that you
jump in the shower because you get
scratches and those scratches on your
body.
You can get staff on those and staff
lives in your nose and it lives in
saliva and it lives in like when you're.
You're doing Jujitsu,
you're awash in bacteria.
A hold weapon.
Gunpoint is this guy showed up in his
driveway.
When is.
This is an August.
Oh my God.
Demands to know who he is.
A little story on it.
Holy Shit.
These motherfuckers are coming over like
the cubes to your house.
If you ever drive down Tim Kennedy's
block mixture.
He knows who the hell you are.
They come on you.
You can't do that shit y'all.
You can't pull up slowly pulling up to
Kennedy's driveway and parking his car.
The side of the collector was at the
wrong end of a barrel.
Whoa.
He demanded know who he was.
It looks like Kennedy is cleaning up the
streets as you saw to tries to clean and
professional mixed martial arts.
Wow.
That is crazy.
Saying that he thought that Usada Rep
might be a terrorist disguised as a
urine collector.
Wow.
That's funny.
Yeah.
That's a dangerous guy to sneak up on
you.
GotTa.
Be Real careful.
That's not a guy you want to fucking.
He's gotta be a little Diaz.
Didn't let him in stone sleep and a lot
of people don't like the idea of just
being stopped.
Like you have to always worry about
that.
That's an added element that you think
of that you have to be stopped in the
middle of your sleep.
Someone can wake you up at 7:30
in the morning thing done and you have
to give them blood and piss right there.
It has to deal.
So you've lost lot and I think so.
I think.
I think at the very least are tasting.
They're testing blood.
I know Nevada was doing urine to.
Well,
if they're still doing urine,
but the more stringent tests apparently
are all blood based,
it's um,
you know,
you have to give them a schedule where
you're going with time.
You're training.
Cowboy got in trouble.
That's tough.
Probably got in trouble because they
said we're at your ranch.
He goes,
well,
I'm at the UFC and he's like,
you have to let us know where you going.
It goes,
well,
doesn't the UFC tell you I'm going to be
here?
He's like,
this is where I'm going.
Like I'm promoting the UFC.
I'm here for the UFC.
I got a fight coming up.
That's why I'm there.
Like they didn't tell you I was going to
be there and so they have to warn him
and give him like,
you're a bad boy because we didn't know
where you were.
We'll send someone here,
mother Fucker,
you know where he is now.
I'm here,
right?
Yeah.
But he apparently he had to like give
them his schedule,
like no matter where you,
where you're going,
you know I'm going to go fishing,
I'm going to be on this river.
Okay.
We're going to show up,
come down there,
the river on a mountain bike,
and uh,
try to collect your pets or your blood.
You have no idea what life is when they
get tracked.
The second,
the second like that.
Oh,
it must be hard to fucking nightmare.
What is this Jamie?
They have an APP now so that they can
check in.
You type in like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
That's so crazy.
That's how far we have to go to keep
people from doing steroids.
Can I track them?
Track them.
Like you're going to follow them with a
drone.
When they came to my house,
I was a criminal.
I'd given up my right.
That's,
it's so fucking bizarre.
And they would show up.
This one dude had it out for me because
I told you I put the,
the fucking out the south during the
pistol one time and I fucked them up.
So now there's little southern guy would
come to me,
show up at my job.
Fucking everywhere.
Hmm.
Like twice.
I gave him pissed,
but at least I got to talk to him.
He said he wasn't a bad guy,
he wasn't like a heavy at all.
The one time I just wouldn't let them
in.
And then he followed me for a probation
violation,
but I proved that wasn't.
That was at the airport and so yeah,
it's when someone,
I can't do it no more.
I couldn't do that.
That would put you in a weird position
with that person.
No,
you have no idea.
There's people who come out of prison,
they put them in that situation and they
fail and they go right back to prison
and they'll tell you,
I never want to be in a halfway house
situation again because it's too,
you know,
it's not really freedom.
It's not really freedom in a way,
you know,
at that level of sharing their weaning
you off of freedom.
That's why it's a halfway house.
Right.
So,
okay,
I'm at the gym.
I leave work.
I got to call them and say I'm headed
over to a 10th planet HQ.
What's the address?
Six O two,
whatever.
And then as I'm leaving now,
let's say you go,
okay,
we're going to go over across the street
to get a protein shake and when you go
over to their places closed,
so he'd go next door or something like
that.
They can violate you for that.
Yeah,
it's tough to,
you know,
no Bible.
It's working,
but it's working and it makes you
accountable.
Yeah.
It makes you accountable.
Important thing when you're,
you're definitely gonna eliminate 90
something percent of the people that'd
be willing to take a chance and take a
steroid.
But then there's always the possibility
that there's people that are ahead of
the curve,
you know,
like we can't think that,
all those times when they,
uh,
had that clear stuff.
When Victor Conte was using that stuff
on his athletes that was undetectable,
they would call it the clear and then
they figured out what the clear was and
now now you can test for it.
But back then nobody had a test for it.
But once,
once they find tests for whatever the
fuck people are using now that are
skirting around tasks,
we're going to go,
oh,
we thought those guys were clean.
Like there's going to be a certain
percentage,
whatever that percentage is,
but it's 10 percent.
There's always going to be a percent
that's trying something.
that's willing to try something.
It's just out of all the people that we
know are clean,
if there's 100 people,
is it one guy that takes a chance and
does something weird and then gets
caught a few years later when they
figured out a test for it might be fake.
The coffee was taken into the different
levels.
Oh,
he was in the sixth day.
Yeah.
Couple of.
And they,
they would be out of your system.
Yes.
Yeah,
in the sixth inning.
Now let me ask you a question.
I know you're not going to say,
I know Jamie's been watching lately.
Jamie,
tell me the truth as pete rose been
killing it lately.
Tell me the truth.
He rose.
What do you mean he'd been killed on
national TV?
Repeat Baseball player.
What's he doing?
He's doing like this analyzing,
but they got him and Alex Rodriguez.
Oh my God.
They killed Joe Rogan.
You've got this is 2016.
Pete rose with a bow tie because pete
rose.
No matter I've never been mad at p rose.
Remember Pete Rose was one of my heroes
though.
Pete rose my heroes.
I've never gotten mad at Pete rose.
He's human,
but in a way how they treat them.
But he was a junkie and he was a piece
of shift for awhile.
Like he was a gambling junkie,
you know,
he was a piece of shit for a while,
but enough fees.
Fucking Pete rose dog.
He's,
I'm telling you.
I watched this show one night and I was
dying.
How funny.
He is like how crazy is and they're
going to keep them around Fox.
I hope they fucking do well.
Did you ever watch him?
Joe?
Anything?
Look,
that's classic.
How old is Pete Rose Now?
Fifties or sixties.
Sixties.
I just feel bad that you know,
there was a,
all the speculation that he had done 75.
Wow.
Just.
Yeah,
there was all that speculation that he
had,
um,
gambled on his own team,
but I don't think that was ever shown.
Listen,
you have to assume I'm a gambling.
You do me a favor.
Jamie,
can you put up for Joe Rogan?
Can you put up pete rose against ron
bone and the all star game?
This is when you.
I had to show people at a bar one that I
go,
you never know who pete rose is not.
Let me just show you pete rose's.
Pete Rose Tackles Ron.
Boom.
But the beauty of this,
it's an all star game.
You never saw this German now.
Oh,
look at you.
You're beside yourself.
Oh No,
no,
because I get allergies.
Jesus.
Shit.
The afternoon.
Oh,
look at this.
Look.
All right.
This is this guy.
How he played like this guy wasn't
American savage.
Who's a barbarian?
Charlie.
This is crazy.
This is still the look at it.
Oh my God.
He just took him out.
He tells them don't ever blocked that
fucking basic gun cock sucker.
Oh,
look at this shit.
Like he was the last of the real fucking
Americans.
He fucked up yet I'm a gambler.
And he wrecked that dude.
He literally tackled him.
Oh my God.
Full shoulder down.
Now,
here's the beauty.
If you put on yelled at him,
let me tell you something.
Nineteen 73.
I was 10 years old and I went to see the
mets against the Cincinnati reds.
I was in my fucking haven.
It was the fucking all star game.
It was the National League,
uh,
Eastern Conference.
And he beat up.
But housing the second I left there.
Look at us.
I left there.
So fucking happy.
I went there with my mom,
my stepdad.
We was sitting behind Tony Perez family
and Pete rose is beaten up on bud house.
And I left there with my fucking
dickhead.
That chicken pox.
I had the chicken pox.
I went to that game with the fucking
chicken pox.
So here's my question to you.
How come this can happen today?
How come the guy can't run into the guy
at home base today?
That would be a suspension three months
especially for suspension is nothing,
right?
Nothing.
And that was one of the greatest.
Look at that team right there.
That's playing.
That's one of the greatest.
You'll never see anything like that.
Yeah.
That's New York City.
This is fucking tremendous.
Oh my goodness.
This is awesome.
What a fight to cut it off.
What a terrible time to edit it.
That was just.
It was just getting good.
Yeah.
[inaudible] gotten a bunch of his
fights,
right?
Fist fight to use to tackle you at
second,
but you know,
he played baseball.
He Played Cincinnati.
Somebody would get hurt on Cincinnati.
Reds and bench would automatically go to
first and plumber would play like a
plumber was like fucking God.
And he sat by,
you know,
it was just a trump meeting with me and
Goldberg get together.
We talk about the Cincinnati reds
because I grew up on him,
but at this point I think I don't give a
fuck about the hall of fame for Pete
Rose.
I know he gambled on his own thing,
but if you don't,
if you know any history of gambling and
professional sports,
guess what?
Joe Rogan,
the role loses.
They all lose a ton of money.
Tons of money from arch leads to to
fucking Pete rose.
There was another one that used to bet
on,
you know,
these arch leaf that didn't get caught
betting on himself,
but he,
he,
he's known to fucking lose everything.
I'm professional gambling.
These guys all called right from
downstairs.
The only thing,
they're the only ones who did it.
Is that what you're trying to tell me?
I have a brother who's a fucking moron,
but he's married to my sister and I know
he's a dumb fucking loser gambler.
I can't call him and say to him,
listen,
fucking Malique Shaw,
his ankles hurt and tonight bet against
them.
You know,
whatever.
I can't.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
a lot of fucking people do it.
Pete rose,
they hate him.
He used to tell him,
fuck you.
When you play like that,
what do you think?
You don't think your rest of your life
is telling people to go fuck themselves.
Who does that in 1973 and an all star
game doesn't mean anything.
So the players didn't like him like
that.
He,
he was against the fucking system like
since day one.
Then he went and he became a player when
he was gambling on himself.
He was a player manager.
Supposedly.
What's.
Oh okay.
A player manager,
but me and my gambling mind,
he been gambling the whole time.
You know what I'm saying?
That's not to say that it just,
he just started gambling one day.
He been gambling the whole time because
in the seventies it was a little less
frowned upon.
What do you like to dad got this horse
and the third.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And one day that basketball baton,
that football bet becomes a baseball
bat.
Well,
people had bookies were really common.
Common.
Everybody had a book.
It's less common today.
Yes.
Today because everything's done on
computers and people could do stuff like
that.
But,
uh,
30 years ago,
August,
this skinny guy would look at the bar.
You went to [inaudible] and that's the
book that here,
what do you want to do?
You give them cash after three or four
or five weeks starts letting you bet on
credit.
What do you think they're worried about?
Why they keep gambling like that?
Illegal.
Do you think they're worried we're just
going to go crazy.
Just gambled all the money away.
Like what are they worried about?
Like why is it.
Why?
Why would you protect someone from
gambling?
Wait you.
Are you trying to keep people prosperous
by removing the threat?
They can't do it.
So because they can't do it.
A lot of people who'd fallen into
gambling won't because we're going to
protect them from themselves because
that doesn't seem to make any sense to
me.
Some states look upon it like when I was
a kid,
no reasonable.
My parents did numbers and the city is
because they gave you a ticket in the
city and a felony in jersey,
so we'll wait a second.
Joey would all those degenerate
motherfuckers in the tristate area.
What you're telling me is if you got
arrested for gambling in New York City
in the seventies and eighties,
you got a ticket.
The Cop said,
what are we going to do?
I've got a thousand of these
motherfuckers popping apartment
buildings all over the place.
If you went to Harlem in the seventies,
it was all little bodegas and everybody
took action,
whether it was numbers.
The next,
the Brooklyn number,
the Roosevelt number.
Remember there's five numbers that come
out and fucking New York.
They haven't told you.
My grandmother got arrested.
Yes.
You run the numbers.
You run numbers.
It's something that you do in the
neighborhood.
You become a part of it.
You gotta accept.
Okay.
For years.
Everybody.
Well,
I did.
I don't know about you.
Once a month.
Let's pump.
Even if I over exaggerate once a month,
somebody would pull me aside and go,
hey man,
you know anybody who wants to sneakers.
What do you got?
Yeah,
I got commerce.
Okay.
They usually go for 20 for you.
I'll give to you for seven.
You don't even ask.
You just know they're stolen.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not going to embarrass you.
You come to my house.
You're my friend,
right?
Jo,
you come to my house.
Joe,
how you doing?
Hi.
This is kind of embarrassing.
My cousin,
he owns a store and he's having a sale
on TVS.
I know it's 6:00,
it's a little late,
but the trend,
the trends that 400 brand new,
I need 100.
They're in a box with a warranty.
Christmas is coming.
You didn't ask him that.
Stolen.
That's a regular fucking day for a guy
in Pittsburgh,
Connecticut.
Is that more of an east coast thing
where people come to you with the open
van?
Well,
I'm not an open van.
I'm talking not people,
not strangers.
I'm talking about Jamie.
Jamie and Jamie's got a cousin that gets
watches.
He gets the best watch in the world.
My lamp on top $52,000.
But Jamie get them to 22 cash.
Went 2020 goals to the guy and Jamie
gets to off the top.
Are you going to torture Jamie and
embarrassing like so when did you get
this?
Am I going to get arrested?
No.
Give him the 22 grand and move on with
your fucking life.
Right?
Is that bad Karma?
I who know.
Buy Stolen goods?
No,
because Martha gets the insurance back
from you and they get an even higher.
They get,
they get the retail back.
Don't even get the wholesale totally
makes out.
If you take it off,
somebody is watching him put a gun to
his head,
then you've got to bump into something
bad,
right?
The physical act of taking from a
person's digital from no matter what
this something involved,
but you don't have nothing to do with
it.
Somebody shows up at your doorstep.
It's two weeks away from Christmas.
What a surprise.
You have the Nintendo game my son wants,
or the ps three or the PS.
How much of those things brand new,
much 300 brand new.
I show up at your house for a buck and a
quarter with three of them.
You're going to take all three of them.
I know a dude who thought he was buying
a stereo,
but he's actually buying bricks.
He got one of those stereotypes that
he's a footpath a moment.
He stopped at the street and bought it
from a guy named Jamal.
I had a guy.
I was buying pet food.
I pulled into this parking spot.
I got out and this dude literally opened
the van like he was going to take me in
and fuck me.
Like I was like some little kid.
He was about to scoop up out of the
woods and like it was a molester and I'm
like,
what?
Like what do you,
what do you got?
And he's like,
stereotypes,
you want to buy a stereo?
I was like,
this is the weirdest.
He's.
He opened up the door like as people
parked the car and like it was literally
like,
Hey man,
you want some of this?
Like what?
You're asking for trouble if you do
business.
One of those guys,
that's the most obvious shit ever.
You know?
He's just randomly trying to sell a
stereo to the back of a van.
Now.
What are these things that they do in
whatever,
like the people go when they have,
what do they call junk at sea?
When I was a trunk.
It's.
No,
no,
I'm sorry.
The thing off the fucking five that you
always see in the movies and all the
fucking Friday,
they all go to a place and they.
They buy stereos and raider hats.
Swap swap me.
Oh yeah.
Well in that way it's a swap me in
Jersey that called,
what do they call you?
Market?
Something like that.
Yeah.
I used to go to where they used to do
the bicycles,
whatever those street car races and next
door to it they had whatever it was
called and you'd go there and they had
pretty much shit that was stolen.
It was just a festival and they tries to
a table fee because everything was 50
percent off.
Even the sneakers I remember and then we
found that that the guy would go to the
fucking factory and jumped over the
fence and take over the sneakers.
No mistakes.
Irregulars.
They would take those and just sell them
at those for swap,
swap meets,
and then we find that we cut into his
action.
I just want it done.
We,
we,
we cut into that action and the action,
they're not going to.
Those tubes are blocked best prank.
They would throw thousands of amount
with little things like the chemical was
off.
You start blinking too much,
like the chemical would be off.
Then it was pepper spray,
pepper spray,
like people would spray and you can see
what happened.
It's not regular but binocular.
What does that tear gas.
It was like the tickets.
The Spanish kid that was advertising and
we make them jump the fence and we'd
have thousands of tubes and we'd sell
them for fifty cents a piece on Monday,
the sixth and seventh grade virus,
but there wasn't always three kids that
complain.
There was a little like the chemical
imbalance was all delirious.
Yeah.
There's more shenanigans and the east
coast it seems like,
but no,
you know,
cut into that sneaker business who Ross
Ross dress for less.
All those companies that you go in the
genes of 20 percent off because there's
a regular stitch now.
They became the fucking junkets for
those.
You know how you have a friend that has
a bit and then that bit is always
connected to that place.
Like Ross dress for less is sebastian
where every time you go to.
Sometimes I'll even go to Ross because I
think it's a bathroom.
I mean that's like I can't see Ross
dress for less.
Ross dress for less.
Does that a little bit about.
Is this mountain the flip flops shoes
pull shit off the shelf and just fuck
it.
Throws it down the aisle.
That's a funny bit,
but it's one of those.
It just cemented in your head.
If you think about Ross dress for less,
like what are the.
There's gotTa be other bits like that,
right?
Like okay,
Roller Derby's or roller skating rinks.
I take my daughter to a rollerskating
things,
a little party in a roller skating rink.
Every skates around.
You know what I think about Bret Ernst
and it's crazy.
Roller Skater bit.
Remember that bit about the old dude.
That was really good.
That would go to the skating rink and
skate backwards.
It's fuck it was.
I mean he,
he isn't the east coast.
Did you ever go rogue?
Escape that one of those places on
Sunday with Guido and cousin vinny?
No,
I missed a lot of stuff because once I
got into martial arts I didn't want to
do anything that would hurt me outside
of martial arts because I didn't want to
get hurt.
So I didn't want to ski.
He didn't want to ride motorcycles,
didn't.
I didn't want to skate.
I didn't rollerskate I didn't do it.
I did an ice skate.
I don't know how to ice skate.
No,
fuck you.
I bowled.
I got a bowling ball at some point in
the game.
That wasn't bad.
I'd go to the Bronx and bowl.
I rolled a skate if I went like three
times in the seventh grade and like a
Paramus,
paramus,
New Jersey,
and like a roller rink.
And it was the one that was just.
Oh really?
Staying alive and yeah.
You know,
first I was afraid I was petrified he,
Brett would do this bit and he would do
it with music and they would flash the
lights and shit and he would,
uh,
I don't want to give it away.
I don't think he does anymore.
But if you haven't seen it,
go find it.
If it's online somewhere,
it's serious.
I used to go to the one and I took me
were older than I was and for me it was
just to skate around for them.
It was to pick up checks you following
me and they would get all dressed up and
shit and then they would roll around and
if you want up to a girl and ask her to
roller skate.
That was the beginning of the
relationship,
that type of shit.
And they played disco music and I went
like three times.
It wasn't for me,
but the best thing.
I had a wig and he fell and the weight
fell off everybody surrounding them.
And that was my highlight of the fucking
roller skating rink.
I never went back to the this game.
What did you know?
They,
you just.
Did you have a point in your life where
you knew that you were going to be a
comic?
Did you have like a.
But did you ever like look back at
moments like that where the guy falls
down,
his wig falls off and it's a fucking
your favorite part of the day?
No,
that's.
That was the whole thing like you left
irrational.
I love laughing.
Yeah,
I know you do.
I love laughing at the fucking most
absurd.
Like when I saw a guy get him on a
snowball in New York City on a bus,
like when people throw snowballs at each
other and I was in the back of the bus
and this guy sat in the area where
people get hit with snowballs and the
window was open.
I don't mind.
This motherfucker's going to get hit.
I'm going to forget.
It was like Deja Vu and all of a sudden
sitting in the back of the bus and this
guy's happy.
He's talking in Italian,
blah,
blah.
He was like a tourist.
He was a tourist Italian and it was the
day after the storm and these coasts
where it's sunny out and that snow's
melting,
but kids are rapping.
I don't have school and they're throwing
snowballs.
I got to the boulevard and this guy gets
on the bus,
doesn't close the window.
Rule number one.
Soon as you can in those Kennedy
Boulevard,
you closed the fucking window track
because there's an area.
Then it becomes like apocalypse now.
Then when they threw spears,
then when they went on the lake and
launched and they got really fucked up,
they started getting hit with speeds.
That's how I would get hit with
snowballs and I saw at Joe Rogan,
that guy sitting down laughing and all
of a sudden you can hear the right in
the fucking face and knocked them off
the chair.
He was in the aisle seat and he went
into the middle and he got up and he
kept saying stop,
but the bus stop or the bus and I'm
fucking island with my little buddies in
the back,
you know,
Shit like that.
You cannot write like,
like as a child,
the things you saw like the time I went
to the haunted house,
they take you to like,
oh,
bring them teen castle haunted house.
Me and a bunch of little white Italian
kids were crazy but wouldn't nice
people.
But like three of us thought we were bad
at.
I'm bad boy.
We didn't know is that night east orange
was coming to one of those black
neighborhoods and they got off the bus
and were walking behind them that I seen
one of the kids just start wailing on
Dracula,
just beat my drag.
When you're 13 and you think you're a
bad motherfucker,
but some do the beat and Dracula and the
Brigham,
Teen Castle,
you can't write that shit light.
That'll stay with me forever.
Seeing that in the haunted house.
Till this day I don't go to haunted
houses because some these kids beat up
dracula.
Then they were pulling them out,
Joe Rogan and kicking him and shit.
Nobody in the other goals are trying to
help him.
This only happens in Jersey.
You can't describe these animal
experiences while we were just talking
about what happened at a rangers game.
Oh yeah.
Before we you.
You were talking about this before the
podcast.
I'm glad you brought that up,
but about the raiders come into Vegas
and he retired.
What happened recently?
The raiders game,
Jamie,
where some guy got beaten into a coma.
Critical.
Well,
this was an earlier this month,
October.
It was in critical condition after a
ravens,
raiders game,
30 percent chance to survive and two
guys got arrested.
Yeah,
they just beat him up.
Yeah.
They didn't know what the story was at
the time of this was written.
It was unclear why the altercation
started.
They just started fighting on their way
out the game.
Tom knows then who knows what happened
if that's the case,
but it two on one,
but I mean who even knows what happened?
Who knows what we're talking about the
violence that these games from Russia
came to this.
Is that a preseason at a game?
At the coliseum.
Just fans brutally fighting.
It's happened all.
All,
all the time.
I like any stadium,
just pick a stadium.
Just going to be fights there basically.
Oh my God,
this is crazy.
This guy just dragged this guy that this
other guy was beaten up.
He dragged the guy over the top of the
stairs and then he started beating him
up.
Oh my God.
This is crazy.
This is insane.
And there's no security.
Where the fuck is security?
Well,
the preseason game with the rams,
there was no this,
this happened and something else
happened.
So I guess the rams didn't want to pay
up and the city didn't want to pay up,
but I guess the rams ended up having to
pay up the security at these games.
Now.
A raiders games particularly violent or
is it all sports games?
Well,
at this point,
who the fuck really knows?
There's a couple dodger games and then
not violent at all.
What about shit will philly in the old
days?
I don't know about this new stadium now
with all the.
In the old days that was getting out of
the hell quick time.
Even at the fucking court downstairs.
But uh,
over the last couple of years it's like
they fucked people up.
You're just not getting into a push
fight.
Two cops coming between you.
It's like three guys beating up on it.
These fucking events.
You're going there with your children to
watch a football game.
He hit.
Do you know a guy tried to two men get
prison for dodgers stadium?
Jesus Christ,
pretty sure after fight after baseball
game.
Oh Man,
God damn it.
Well this guy was the one that they,
he had a blood clot and they couldn't
find the killers.
So they went to the tape.
I mean they narrowed it all the way down
to the tickets for a stupid fucking
game.
Listen,
I could go to a game and have a good
time and yell and scream and get three
bids and all sudden like,
oh yeah,
like the giants and the cowboys.
Ah,
that's it.
Yeah.
But now it's like people come up to you
and punch in the fucking head if you
like somebody else or if you're walking
into the stadium that team lost and you
have that shirt on.
But if it's the certain.
Do certain teams have like a fan
mentality?
You know,
like there's certain teams and other
sports with like
doesn't Manchester United?
Jamie knows something about soccer,
right?
Don't they have like a certain,
like rabid
fan personality,
hooligans.
This menu,
I think it's allowed each team over
there,
they all have their little sect,
their club and they just kinda bought
Brah.
I don't know just what they do and not
just in college football also at these
stadiums.
I never.
They don't,
they just,
just this year I think a lot of drinking
in some stadium.
The college it was up until maybe like a
year or two ago.
You weren't even allowed.
I just went to a game at Ohio stadium.
They should allow them to drink and
you're only allowed to get like beer
maybe even so like there's no liquor but
that's just there.
I don't know how it is all over the
tailgate and Joe Rogan.
That's where the damage is done for
sure.
But don't allow them to keep the party
rolling while they're up in the stands
on your will stop after like half time
in some places.
Years ago.
I know stadium stopped in the third
quarter.
Art,
our
discussion this morning was about the
building,
the stadium right across from the
Mandalay Bay,
like with the,
the thinking of building and I'm like,
you know,
man,
a fucking Sunday to get outta here now.
Let me ask you this.
Is there a benefit to keeping like if
they say if they bought a team that's
for sale,
like the raiders,
let's just say the raiders,
is there a benefit to keeping that name
or is there a benefit to stardom?
It's going to be in Las Vegas.
Benefit to changing the name will.
They're going to call them the Las Vegas
raiders,
but because of what people call it with
a Brendan,
it's the raiders.
They're going to keep the radios and
they'll keep the black and silver and
the whole.
I mean wide changes.
The whole mentality now they're in
fucking right now where they were in
Vegas.
That's so crazy.
They're going to be in Vegas and this is
their stadium.
Las Vegas Committee Sends Raiders
Stadium Plan to Governor.
It looks insane.
I'll tell you what,
man,
I've never been to a live football game.
Not a big ass crazy nfl game,
but I could only imagine.
The energy must be insane.
It must be insane when you get a 100,000
people screaming at the top of their
lungs.
When some shit goes down,
it makes you wonder,
man,
what it would have been like to see the
colosseum in Rome.
I mean imagine what that must have been
like.
And with real blood,
real blood's got chopped swords and
shit.
Russell Crowe strapping motherfuckers.
It's like that is the same.
We will looking at it essentially it's
the same progression from like Pete rose
to today's baseball,
you know,
versus like gladiators to like some
crazy football game.
It's like it's just,
there's just,
there's no way we want to slide back
that sword fighting shit again.
If that would be the one thing like
yeah,
you can't do that.
One thing I noticed the last couple of
weeks because you know,
during the year I don't really sit and
watch baseball.
It's around the world series that I'll
watch a game.
So the other thing,
the green room,
we're watching it now,
they even have like Joel pieces,
jaw piece,
tons of protection now like.
So if you're batter of you get hit with
a ball.
Yes.
So if you're a battery or a right handed
batter,
your,
your helmet now comes down to here.
So all you could see as the ball.
Oh,
that's weird.
So if the blue.
Yeah,
some of these jaw got broken or
something like that.
They're looking to protect your pete
rose's game.
He was a fucking gladiator.
But when I was a kid,
I remember that's when that guy,
Tony Conigliaro,
is that his name,
the guy who got hit with a ball.
Who's the guy that got hit with a ball?
He was a big player in the Boston Red
Sox.
You got hit with a ball and was never
the same again.
And Sam wasn't a fucking.
I was a baseball fan until I started
martial arts,
so till I was like 14 or 15 and uh,
I forget the story,
but I remember thinking,
man,
I did not know a baseball could fuck you
up that bad.
This guy was essentially net Tony
Conigliaro.
Yeah,
that's it.
So he got hit with his baseball and he
was just never the same again.
And he was a star player before he got
hit and sort of never recovered.
Was All fucked up afterwards.
But that,
um,
I don't remember when he died,
but I believe he died young,
90 an hour,
80 year,
state even faster.
I mean,
some guys like Roger Clemens.
What would you throw in his prime in the
800?
You know,
this was the seventies,
right?
Yeah.
So the eighties,
they still weren't the,
you know,
it was still growing.
Ada.
I mean the technology might have been a
little wrong,
you know,
steroids,
they weren't a lot of steroids.
So many.
So you have to just still.
Yeah,
still.
Yeah.
You had to.
Um,
what were you going to say,
Jamie?
The guy closes for the cubs that pitches
last night.
Chapman,
he's throwing 102 miles an hour.
Fast balls on Sunday.
That was fast.
It breaks bats and shit.
And that's so fast.
That hits your kneecap at that one.
It just shattered it.
Let's chat.
Is it
crazy ability,
you know,
I mean,
you have ability to take a baseball bat
and base our baseball rather and just
basically held something in the head.
You could throw it like that guy.
I could throw a baseball at a dog and
Kol,
like if you want it to that kind of
accuracy and speed,
you know,
they think that might've been one of the
reasons why human beings evolved like
that.
Our brains evolved.
That was one of the considerations.
So they're trying to figure out which
what causes the brain to double.
Our brain doubled over a period of 2
million years.
Apparently it's,
it's just giant mystery.
They don't know why.
There's a bunch of thoughts as to why
did it.
People started eating more meat,
started cooking their meat.
They get get them more access to
nutrients,
but another weird one is they think it
might've had something to do with the
throwing arm.
Then when people figured out that they
could pick stuff up and throw it at
something that they started getting
clever and that's when they started
devising
solutions to problems and it gave them
more access to food because they could
kill animals better.
So they were throwing rocks like
squirrels and shit and eating them.
So what you mean to tell me it's on its
own.
Our brain has doubled in size over a
period of 2 million years.
The human brain doubled,
was a long met.
None of that was a long time ago.
Oh yeah.
But there's more information.
There was no books back then.
There was during the time that human
brain doubled.
We were basically going from these,
uh,
you know,
more primitive hominids to becoming a
human being.
And then there was a sort of a period
where things move along at a fairly slow
pace,
but then all of a sudden something
explodes over what seems like a long
time,
but 2 million years is not that long in
evolutionary terms.
So something happened when we were some
sort of monkey creature and during that
time there was a change where we mutated
in our brain,
doubled in size and we became way more
sophisticated.
No Fun.
The Fun Shit is to think that that was
aliens.
The Fun Shit is to think that aliens
came down and uh,
you know,
put sperm and a monkey or did some tests
with,
you know,
took one of the early primates and added
alien DNA to it and dropped it back off.
And that's why the brain got so big so
quick.
But it's,
we've figured some shit out,
man.
And the people that didn't figure it
out,
they didn't live,
you know,
we probably figured out high spaces keep
you away from cats,
got to climb up high.
You got to figure out how to invent
weapons.
You gotta like soft.
Like we,
we didn't.
Uh,
we didn't get the fangs.
We didn't get the claws,
but we've got the crazy brain and we
went to crazy brain option over 2
million years somehow or another for
whatever reason it grew.
It's pretty nuts when you think about it
because every other animal on this
fucking planet is basically like.
There's some advanced animals like
chimps and dolphins and some other
advanced animals,
you know,
that we think are real smart,
like octopus when we're not exactly sure
how their little brains work.
But when it comes to doing the kind of
shit that we can do to the planet,
which we fly,
we changed the temperature of buildings.
We project video,
you know,
we,
we can film things in real time and then
show them seconds later on this little
tiny thing that slips right into your
pocket.
I mean we're,
we're on some weird complete different
level than everything that exists in
terms of if maybe not far,
not our actual overall intelligence,
our ability to change our environment.
It changed space around us.
There's nothing like us,
man.
That's who knows what the fuck cause
that they don't know.
Transplant candidate thinks it's
mushrooms,
so he thinks,
thinks there's a,
it's called the stoned ape theory.
He thinks he's ancient monkeys,
found some mushrooms,
atum and then,
well blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Got In tune with the mother.
Joined Diaz sometimes to kind,
kinda leave me the fuck alone.
He's dead.
Who gives a fuck?
Fuck.
I'm talking about 2007 thing if one,
lesson chimp with acid.
Anyway,
we're talking about doubling of the
human brain.
How the fuck did we even get onto that?
Who the fuck knows?
He just came out of it.
I'm dealing with these sprays and shit.
You can't scare me like this shit on a
fucking doing a 50 milligram Brownie and
you've got to hit me with these stories
about the human brain pictures.
That's TMZ.
That's what happened.
People want to listen to TMZ and they
need fucking more a space.
Like when you got your computer after a
month you realize what the fuck?
I need more space.
I got born,
I got a UFC,
I got,
you know,
the family,
we run on a hard drive space.
We need space.
It's very important for ourselves,
you know,
will get stronger.
We'll get fucking bigger.
Look at these kids in football now.
They're fucking huge.
These kids that,
these animals,
these kids.
Yeah.
How,
when we're talking about the difference
in baseball pitchers quit baseball
players back then were throwing what was
like a super fast Nolan Ryan,
Nolan,
probably the fucking throwing to eat
since day one.
That fucking guy.
And uh,
how fast did he throw?
Like it'd be 90,
but you figure you take a guy that
pitches 85 were good control.
Okay,
well I'm talking about gun control is I
can hit any other nine Elvis's every
time I pitch right from how far away is
like 60 slash 60 feet?
60 point six inches.
Okay.
So you take one of those guys don't
through what we have today.
You know,
you put them with.
What's the guy that we would think
really highly of Marinovich yeah.
Marble intervention.
Okay.
You put them with like,
I'm a really rich guy that strengthen
those fucking all those muscles that
they haven't figured out before.
You know that,
that that's quick.
You know,
how long do those guys last?
Jamie?
Few years.
But Nolan Ryan,
he lasted a long ass time.
Yeah,
but they had to take the surgeries and
the surgeries to have that type of,
you know,
because it's not just your arm.
Okay,
let's pull.
It's not yours.
It starts when you picked that fucking
leg up.
When you pick that leg up,
the energy of that leg on your own time,
not the next time you smoke a joint.
Late night,
you know,
insomnia,
just and put up the 10 best pitches and
look what that front leg does and how
that front leg also controls that time.
There's a pitcher now that pitches for
Chicago that you switched sitting there
and you're waiting for the ball.
The foxy door.
What the fuck?
They already have flopped because it's a
fuckin angle.
It still leg.
He pops it out.
He drops the ball.
It's that whole body technology in
there.
So there's a guy,
there's a fucking dude with glasses and
Iowa right now.
I got the training for this right or
wrong,
you know the major league right now
doesn't give a fuck about strengthening
your arm and all that.
How can we take my guy from 98 to one?
Oh,
four.
And have them be able to throw at one.
Oh,
4:20
pictures the most.
Hm.
And I'll just put them in every three
games to just kill motherfuckers.
Do you understand me in the seventh
inning when you're getting momentum in
comes this guy that throws one on fourth
and he's going to throw it's nine
pitches.
He's going to throw 12 pitches and
you're out of there.
I really don't because remember,
the faster the ball comes in,
the faster the ball goes out.
Always remember that too.
If you live by the sword,
you die by that motherfucking sort of.
Somebody hits a home run.
It's because he popped the 98
motherfucker that made a mistake and put
it in who?
Loeb and his gorilla,
because that's all it determined.
It's just A.
It's like a game of inches.
He just dropped it.
It just dropped a little bit too much
for one of these fucking things.
Now on the other side,
you got to Marinovich that comes in and
takes that guy that batch to 90,
keeps them healthy,
give some conditioning stuff out of the
shoulder.
What's the recovery?
Because the recovery in that game is the
whole game,
Joe,
right?
The recovery is the whole thing and this
fucking along those guys.
Two or three years later,
that's too much on that.
All those 10 meets the surgery.
Will the shoulders alone muscles
combined and to throw that particular
look how many muscles I have involved,
especially if it come look at this,
try this on your own and I had no
flexibility.
It's got to go at least all the way the
fuck back this and as that leg drops,
look what that arm it has to come in.
Perfect.
Over the top and then down across and
now the follow through is the most
important.
Yeah,
it's got to come.
And that's a thing for if you throw a
ball like a girl,
and I don't mean like a girl knows how
to throw a ball,
but you know what I'm talking about.
If you throw a ball and spastic like as
Steven Seagal.
Yeah,
people will never respect you.
It's a real issue like you,
you could suck it a lot of stuff.
You could suck at basketball.
How about this?
You could suck at like throwing a free t
three a free throw and people laugh.
Ha ha ha ha.
But if you throw the first pitch and you
throw that like some uncoordinated
spazz,
if you hit this fucking first pitch,
dark it off the ground like you're a
loser.
Like there's a.
there's a harshness like people get.
It's like some school yard shit
you just said free throat.
You reminded me of something I saw.
I haven't heard anybody bring this up
yet.
Someone made stevie wonder shoot a free
throw and they have it on video.
Did he nail it?
No.
He missed it.
Well obviously terribly,
but I don't know how this movie and you
don't want to let him know he missed it.
They could have all just played along
and made it.
Someone should have caught it.
The other said dropped a ball
right through the net.
They given another shot.
It's just says it over and over again.
But Oh,
why don't they just let him figure it
out where it is.
If he keeps throwing it,
how long do you think it would take
before we figured out where it is?
A long he wouldn't even know how to
install it.
That's terrible that they even did this
as well.
If there was no one in the room and you
could get,
let him use like echolocation what he
yelled out.
Hello with this beautiful voice.
Hello.
Maybe you could figure out,
you know,
because deaf guys apparently are blind
guys rather apparently can do that to a
certain extent.
Like they hear sound bounce off things,
you know,
how far away things are.
But how would he know where the net is
if you put my waist right in front of
it?
If you go.
The thing is 15 feet.
Right?
Exactly.
From us right now.
Stevie,
I'll be under them that you just keep
going into your head.
You fucking hit it.
Success.
What's the concept of 15 feet to a guy
who was blind,
you know?
Do you think he lost 10 feet in the air?
Right?
Ten feet in the air?
Yeah,
that's A.
I was going to figure that out.
I just never thrown anything before
either.
But that's not embarrassing.
I mean,
especially at Stevie wonder's blind.
But if even if it was a regular guy that
sucked at basketball and through a free
throw,
it would be funny.
Be Stupid.
But funny,
but if you fucking missed that first
pitch,
if they ask you,
hey joey,
I hear you're going to be in town,
you want to throw out the first pitch
for the game.
They're like,
ah,
yeah,
yeah.
I used to play a lot of baseball when I
was a kid.
I'll fucking do that.
You go out there.
I'll full of piss and vinegar.
You want.
I wouldn't even.
I wouldn't make 60 feet.
Right?
There is no way.
Oh yeah.
Gary Dell bought day from the stern
show.
Here.
He goes,
no way.
I would make 60 feet right here it goes.
Let's see what he does.
Oh,
they're good.
They're all talking about it.
Like it's an event.
Maybe one of the worst ones ever.
Here it is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He throws it and they don't show you.
They actually hear it goes throw it.
Oh my God.
It didn't go anywhere near him.
Yeah.
He completely missed to make it any
worse than it is though,
because it went all the way to the
catcher.
Right?
Yeah.
You should get made fun of him for sure.
They'd been making fun of him.
That's why there's a whole piece about
this,
but do you think.
You said this is what happens when you
get made fun of this is what happens
when you throw like that.
Oh,
for sure.
You get made fun of.
Yeah.
I thought you were saying that he missed
because he gets made fun of like they've
destroyed his confidence to the point
where you can't throw a baseball.
I get it.
It's a good point though.
There's something about throwing.
Oh,
see,
they have the worst first pitches ever.
Yeah.
Ip in that.
I'd be in that for sure.
I can't really throw the ball.
I tried Puma football a couple months
ago.
Reference.
Horrific.
Really?
Football.
It's gone.
Oh,
this guy's had in my shoulders is gone.
I'm living on fucking smoke and my
shoulders.
There's nothing in there.
I don't know how they're not hurting me.
I don't think so.
Did you get an Mri?
What?
I'm going to waste their fucking time.
What can you not do with it?
Can you put your arms over your head?
Flexibility.
You know,
my flexibility is halfway there.
I can't do flies anymore.
That type of shit.
You know,
the thing that helps me a lot now is the
bat the way that bats are great.
You know,
why aren't you taking that guy's a
kettlebell classes at,
uh,
the Jujitsu school.
You go to Joe,
Joe,
Joe Alvarado.
Yeah.
I've been told is a kettle Jujitsu,
Jujitsu.
Bad Ass man.
I've seen his instagram video,
right?
Dude,
man.
I went in there the other day and I want
in there a little early.
They have class at 12 and it wasn't
doing anything.
I want to net 11.
There's usually some guys when I was
messing around with some guy and my
professor Alvarado is,
let me teach you something joey,
that's perfect for you.
And he stayed with me for 30 minutes and
we just worked this half guard sweep
that was just tremendous.
Joe Rogan.
Simple shit for a fat dude.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
uh,
they teach that old manage it,
so it's just less movement and get the
job done effectively.
He's a great dude,
but he,
we worked in off of a.
At first he goes,
Joe,
you're gonna have a problem with this.
Let's get a Kettlebell and working off
of a Turkish got.
It'll be a lot easier for you to develop
the movement.
There was basically,
boom,
get the under hook,
grab the arm and just flip over that.
But he turns it very,
uh,
he's a good man.
So when you do Turkish getups,
it doesn't bother your shoulder.
I could do a Turkish get up to the
point.
Like for,
I can't lie.
I can't do point.
You can't get to the fifth part.
Boom here to the top.
Okay.
So you don't ever stand up all the way?
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
So you just hip up and you have the from
my hip.
I do more my hands to be honest with
you.
The shoulder,
like I said,
that little weighted bat is tremendous,
but it.
Let me ask you this.
Is it.
I'm the reason why you don't get up.
Is it because of the weight or your
shoulders?
It's my weight and the weight.
It's the weight on the shoulders
combined.
Well,
you know what,
you can do the model.
No,
no,
no.
I can do the leg thing and go from
there.
No,
no,
I'm good that that's one thing,
but what I'm saying is with the,
especially with the Turkish get up,
like people underestimate the benefit of
doing it with even know.
Wait like you just doing it as a
posture.
Just lying on your back,
straighten your arm up and going through
all the motions,
propping up on your elbow,
you know,
going up on the hip,
hoisting your hip hop lyft net,
one leg,
getting an underneath you,
standing up straight and then fully
standing straight with your arm
extended.
If you just go through that series of
motions have been carrying a Kettlebell.
That's an professor.
Alvarado is Walmart.
He does that with no.
No,
no Kettlebell.
No.
That's good.
Just that as a warmup.
I mean people don't it if you don't
move your body around a lot like that,
it's hard to move your body around like,
you know what I started doing recently
that I haven't done it forever.
Jumping rope.
I started jumping.
I fucking love it.
It's hard to.
Yeah,
it's hard to.
Minutes is 20 minutes of jogging to.
It's hard to do three minutes like
around like in between like a set,
the boxing timer and I do three minutes.
It's fucking hard.
It's hard.
You're like this shit.
He feel pretty good and then about 30
seconds and you're like,
oh,
I gotta fucking concentrated here.
I've got to make this.
I'm feeling it in my feet started
hurting.
I'm like,
oh,
this is one of those things.
If you don't do it,
you think it's easy and then once you do
it,
you realize are you going to get in
shape for this too?
Like everything else.
Your body's not used to jumping around
like that point and going,
going,
don't do anything.
But if you can do it,
I would imagine there'll be tremendous
for your footwork and you free your
agility and your foot strength and all
the strength in,
in all those connecting ligaments
because essentially what you're doing is
little tiny plyometrics.
You know,
you're jumping,
you're not,
you're not getting full extended
explosion movements,
but you're getting these little jumping
bounces where you know,
you're,
you're with me.
I'm 196 or something like that and 196
pounds going,
going,
going on my feet.
That's great for you.
You know,
it develops real strength in your feet.
I got sore in weird places for like
three weeks when I first started putting
to rankle yeah,
my ankle.
My calves got super tight,
like it was really fucking up my
kickboxing because I would try to kick
and I'd be worried that like my calf was
going to lock up.
Like it was real sore,
like a in a,
in a way that,
uh,
I thought I was hitting with those Hindu
squats and I like to do.
I think I thought that was hitting my
calves and up.
I guess not.
There's no substitution for that little
bouncing.
You know where I got it from him,
Lance Armstrong's podcast.
I was listening to Lance Armstrong's
podcast and he was talking about his son
being friends with.
He's friends with Brett farve and Brett
farve came to his house in the son plays
football,
so he asked his son,
he goes,
Hey,
do you skip rope?
Like this is the first thing he asked,
and he had talked to some other guy who
was also some big time football player,
big time football coach rather,
and he's like,
do skip rope and the kids.
And he said,
no.
So you got to skip rope and the same
thing Brett Farve said you got to skip
rope.
Like there's something about jumping
rope that for like footwork and
movement.
And so I said,
all right,
I'm going to start doing that and right
away I realized like God damn it,
how come I haven't been doing this
forever?
I should have been doing this forever.
Open everything.
I got one of those everlast while my
daughter go and do a layer on top ones
and she left it out there one day and I
go,
let me try this old school.
I do like 32 seconds at those.
Did you rip your feet apart?
No.
That's one thing that I got those cube
does it have for going feet.
That'll fuck around Jack.
This was coming up when I was a kid.
Everybody
you talked to tell you how to jump rope.
I used to jump rope at night with no
weights.
Basketball workout was 20 slash 30
minutes of jumping rope and then I would
sit on the wall,
just sit to condition my thighs.
Twenty,
30 minutes.
That was it.
Yeah.
That wall sit thing.
That was always big.
And Karate schools was a big wolf.
Say the spine to the wall.
Had a wall looking straight ahead.
If you could do it,
you know,
you a little.
But then they did horses.
Horses in class.
Always motherfuckers that would sit
there and go 20 minutes.
What?
I think it's probably better to run
stairs.
I'm uh,
I'm on the run stairs.
Are you really running them to know I
have hills near my house,
you know,
hills near my house.
I do some sprints up those on occasion.
Fairly rare.
But um,
the thing that I like about that though
is that it's like you're exploding your
body forward.
I think like that static hold of like a,
there's benefits to that for sure,
but I just don't think he can fuck with
plyometrics.
Essentially what you're running a hill,
you're essentially dealing like one
legged plyometrics.
You're just exploding,
exploding,
exploding for the workout that you do.
When the Diet you do,
they say that you have to recommend
running once a week.
Sprints that primal diet,
they say absolutely like 10:40
yard sprints.
It's good for you.
I'm a 40 year,
I believe.
I just need a heart attack at this point
in my life.
For Awhile I was going crazy when I
couldn't find that.
Figuring out the cardio.
Why wasn't breathing?
I would go into that fucking north
Hollywood park,
walk around with a farm.
It was kettle bell and then I would like
do 10 sets of swings and they'll go let
me try some fucking sprints and that
would do it.
Not realizing like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I could pull something here that can
then retain.
This isn't just a fucking,
you know,
like you know,
you're not warmed up properly for that
shit.
Right.
I remember going to track as a kid
because they tried to tell me during the
off season basketball players with a
high jump to stay in shape and we had
this guy real wolf and I read wolf was
the one of the assistants at the fucking
Olympics.
Great Guy and you know he was at the
bend squats.
That was this big fucking squats to get
the fuck.
Yeah.
I'll go down on the squad and popping
into jumping rope and those fucking
spreads.
And we used to run hills in north Bergen
because it's the second hill.
He is fucking,
you know,
that's a nightmare type shit.
I'm good.
No running hills.
It's hard,
but you know,
it's the hardest shit.
Running sand dunes run in sand dunes is
dark death.
That's you just legs have nothing.
They're going through that sand and
you're barely making progress.
Listened my fight with Shane car.
We've got canceled because I don't need
the fucking dudes.
All right.
Where's Shane Shankar?
When going?
Shane?
Carolyn's going to rising.
Okay.
Yeah.
He couldn't take it no more on the
silence.
He's like,
fuck it.
I guess he wants to have some fun while
he's still Shankar,
when I salute that he could still hit
hard in a month.
Did you see that?
Jason knows fight.
Do you see what crazy Jason Ellis did?
Jason Ellis fought Shane Carwyn with one
hand tied up or Shane Karlyn had his
right hand tied up to his body and so
Jason,
I was like,
you don't realize how big Shane car is.
Like Jason knows is not the tiniest guy.
You know.
He's probably about 200 pounds.
Who is standing next to Shankar when it
is almost comical.
How will you this?
Look how big car one is.
I mean,
he's a giant.
He's a fucking giant and he's got one
arm tied up.
Look at this and he looks good dude.
Like physically he looks jacked like he
hasn't fought in a while,
but obviously he's been working out.
I mean he looks better than he did the,
did the last time I saw him.
The last time I saw him he was
recovering from some injuries and he was
still in the UFC.
So apparently he's a free agent and I
think,
you know,
he's,
he's fighting for rise and I'm pretty
sure,
I mean,
I know we put it on his instagram page,
but uh,
he came to man,
he really kind of wrong.
Oh,
that was one.
That was one punch.
Did he hit him with that wasn't even the
punch that,
that chaos is it?
No,
that,
that was like at the end of a round I
think.
See,
this is where it came from right here.
So that was the second one.
I mean that one really came,
I'm like,
you could see when he was down he was
like,
fuck,
I mean that guy is so goddamn big
Carlin's as gigantic human.
So they were talking about setting him
up with fader,
like fate or versus car one.
I don't know if that's gonna happen,
but if that does,
I'm in,
I'm paying to see that.
That's a dangerous fight for fader now
was writing for a dangerous Pfizer.
Japan.
Okay.
So essentially the same guy who is in
charge of a pride for awhile.
Yeah.
And uh,
I believe so.
And so,
uh,
if he goes over and fights,
if Karlyn goes over and fights in Japan
and he fights fade or as a giant fight,
afraid offered,
fought fabio Maldonado and barely
squeaked by a fight,
a lot of people thought that he should
have lost you got hurt.
Fabio Maldonado tagged them in it.
There's no shame in that.
Fabio,
Fabio Maldonado is a very good boxer.
He rocked glover to Sherra before glover
finished him off.
And,
uh,
it was just tough shit.
He's a tough,
tough guy.
They always call that poor guy in like
they always Fabio's life.
Who are we going to get fired?
Well,
who will be this fucking wacky to fight?
I should know this.
Fabio.
Mom,
do you remember how he saved that fight
in Australia somewhere in Brazil some
way.
Steve Bay and heavyweight steep emile
chick when Steve Bay's just fucking
tearing through the ranks,
right?
Steve Bay's trying to get a shot at the
title and he fights Fabio Maldonado.
It just,
I mean,
Steve Ages ran through them.
It was horrific.
And Steve Bay's a scary guy as a
heavyweight.
And Fabio Maldonado just was not the
same size,
just did not belong in there with them,
you know,
just too big,
too strong,
too fast.
It's too hard.
It was so scary fight.
But um,
when you think about Fabio Rockin fader
and hurting him in his last fight and
you think good lord would,
if he gets hit by a car when like car
car when takes a great shot and he hits
harder than anybody in the division.
He's,
he's probably,
he's probably one of the scariest
heavyweight punchers ever.
Literally ever when he fought mere,
I remember he tied near up in a clench
and just ripped up or cuts to his chin,
his face and put them down and just beat
them down when you're on the ground.
Like car could fuck in Ponch scary
puncher man.
So if he's healthy like he looks like
and that video,
it looks fucking healthy to me and he
looks huge.
It looks like he's like,
well over to 60.
Yeah.
I don't know if fader,
I don't know if that's the kind of fight
he wanted to stage of his life,
you know,
after he fought Maldonado,
he might be looking to fight smaller
heavyweights.
He might be looking to fight bigger
names,
will actually Carmen's pretty God damned
big name as far as the free market.
But who knows what's going to happen,
man.
You know,
with um,
one of the crazy things with all these
new organizations,
whether it's one FC,
whether it's uh,
you know,
fill in the blank Bella tour,
rise in all these other,
like everyone is scrambling to pick up
anybody who leaves the UFC so of
people's contracts are up.
I like,
they're starting to do and they start
bolting over and go into these other
different organizations.
Stuff can get crazy,
like things can heat up and you might
see like another pride ufc type of
rivalry,
which I think would be great for
everybody.
Like if rise and really does take off,
like if rise inputs on fate or versus
shame Darwin.
And then they come up with a bunch of
other crazy fights for the undercard.
You know,
just there's just not right now the same
level of talent available outside the
UFC.
Not right now,
but man,
it's been close a few times and it used
to be,
you know,
obviously it used to be with pride.
It's hard making something like that
happen,
you know,
I feel with like a Shane Carbon for
example.
Shannon Cullen was a great father.
He hasn't been thrown a punch in how
many years?
Um,
he hasn't fought MMA since.
I want to say it's two years ago,
two,
three years.
The in my world,
I don't know.
I'm not the professional here,
but I think the UFC marketing would know
they could do something with Shane.
They passed on them.
Maybe there's something they could do.
The heavyweight division is packed.
I don't know.
I don't know the parameters of this.
Yeah.
You know,
I like when a fighter hasn't
fought more than a year or two or maybe
even three.
I think about comedy,
Joe Rogan and I think about if I just
didn't do any here for three years,
what would I be ready for?
What would you,
you didn't do any comedy for three
years,
what would you honestly booked yourself
for?
And fucking December.
It's October 30.
First,
what would you book yourself on December
the garden?
You know,
you do like the laughing skull in
Atlanta.
Okay,
nice.
A cool intimate little room.
Very quiet and Cedar might not have a
lot of money and the rise in might have
offered them a big channel.
I understand all these parameters,
but I'm saying to you is,
you know,
it's like the GSP thing that was going
on and maybe they weren't what they were
and I think even as a fighter to three
years,
shit is fucking changed.
Yes and no.
Here's the.
No,
depends on if you're still training,
see if you decide to take some time off
because you have nagging injuries or
some fighters like that.
Joseph Valtellina guy we were talking
about earlier,
he stepped back because of concussion
syndrome because he was getting.
He,
you know,
he had too many hits to the head and so
he recognized it was having some real
symptoms and he said no after resigned.
So he gave up his belt and taking two or
three years off.
If you're having any sort of real
problem,
maybe if you've got a reoccurring back
injury,
which I know Shane had some bad habits.
He had surgery for.
Yes.
So maybe taking that time off.
So it was junior dos Santos was his last
loss and that was UFC 1:31
and wow.
Two thousand 11.
So that's five fucking years ago.
Almost five and a half years ago.
Guy's the heavyweight division,
has come and gone in five years.
That's a lot.
People want to come back and now two,
one slash 70.
One 70 has come and gone.
Tyrone Woodley is the champion and one
of the boy's number one.
These kids weren't even around when GSP
fucking dropped off.
Our Tyrone Woodley was.
Well not Stephen Tom.
I mean it's a whole breath of fresh air
that comes into it is I think when
Michael Bisping was pretty smart trying
to get GSP to fight him in Toronto.
Still at Man.
Fuck yeah,
that's a great one.
I don't know if George wants to fight at
one 85.
I think George has even said that he
could make 1:55,
you know,
the difference between the size of guys
today versus the way they were then.
It's no guys are way more sophisticated
about weight cutting and I don't think
George lifts as much weights anymore.
I don't think it's as big as it used to
be.
Who the fuck knows,
man?
You know,
I don't.
If the guy wants to compete,
the game moves,
moves very fast.
[inaudible] has moved so much in two,
three years that,
you know,
they got a lot of these people that are
watching UFC eat.
They don't even really know who Shane
Koyczan one is.
We've got a whole new batch of audience
that's coming.
That is true.
Even with GSP,
I'm a fan of GSP.
I love to see him fighting it,
but I had to ask myself questions.
I was
like,
I don't want to learn.
It's like watching a fucking shark tank.
You know what I'm saying?
You want to learn.
Well,
I think the UFC is argument as far as
what I had heard and this is all that
shit I read online.
I don't.
I don't talk to the UFC interested,
we read different dumb shit,
but they there,
what I'd read online was that they were
not in agreement with how much money was
going to cost to promote a fight with
them and that the people that watched
the fight today that are fans of Ronda
Rousey and the fans Ican,
conor mcgregor and all these current UFC
fighters that maybe these fans that have
only been fans for a couple of years,
they kind of forgot what I was thinking
three years run the party,
but she don't think that it would take
one,
one fucking promotional special.
One thing they do on Fox or people
remember just watch some of the fucking
epic fights with John Fitch,
with Bj,
Bj Penn,
you know,
watch him submit Matt Hughes when Matt
Hughes at the top of the world,
watched him beat down Matt Serra after
Matt Serra stomped him and won the
title.
You watch some of those fights and then
you hear him talk and see what a
gentleman he is.
Come on,
man.
Come on guys.
Golden.
I love him to Golden.
Even the foreign names you mentioned
that fucking dying.
This was.
I agree.
You know what?
I think a guy like gsps to do,
he's got to do a tune up fight.
I really believe that.
I think that would help everybody.
I think that's what you would do in
boxing.
The only one that never did that as
sugar ray Leonard went out of retirement
right to Marvin Hagler.
Oh right,
right in there.
Just jumped right into Marvin fucking
hagler and everybody was like,
you're crazy.
You need a tune up fight.
And apparently he had some gym.
Fine.
So they set up some smokers in the gym
just sorta like we were talking about
earlier that they do with the moisture
that he beat him.
Beat him by decision.
Very controversial fight though.
Some people think that Marvin should
have one.
I would say it's probably one of those
fights where it was almost 50 slash 50.
Most my friends,
it was at least amongst a lot of people.
I knew a lot of people thought that
Marvin had did more damage.
It landed the hardest shots with sugar I
was dealing with.
Just throw a pity pat punches and it
wasn't good enough.
And Marvin was chasing them down.
I don't know,
it's a,
I'd have to watch it again as an adult
who understands fighting better.
But,
uh,
whatever it was,
he didn't get destroyed.
And that's better than you could say for
a lot of people that fought hagler.
Hagler was fucking Hagler.
That's the haggar that crushed John the
beast.
Mugabi remember that shit.
That's the Marvin Hagler that beat the
fuck out of Tommy hearns.
I mean,
Marvin Hagler was a monster when I was a
kid.
They had this fucking TV show that they
showed were haggard was training for my
staff ham show and uh,
he was running on the beach in the Cape
in the winter.
He's running on the sand and Cape Cod
screaming war,
just running,
screaming,
Wah,
Wah.
This who's just sure at shredded.
I mean,
Marvin Hagler in his prime had one of
the best physiques ever for a boxer.
And he was in supreme condition and he
was known for maybe not being like the
slickest most technical boxer,
like maybe sugar ray was or Roberto
Duran was.
But overwhelming discipline and drive
and ferocity who will just break dudes
down,
you know like you did with the Tommy
hearns fight,
was the purest expression of Marvin
agler.
Just skimming.
These guys are fighting for the fucking
middleweight championship of the world.
It's a giant fight between two
superstars.
And what do they do?
They just throw caution to the wind and
meet in the center of the ring and start
throwing bombs.
There was no boxing in that fight.
That was a war.
That was a crazy war.
Throw that shit up.
Shut up.
Marvin hagler versus Tommy hearns.
Fuck.
Because that was like talking to them.
Put this motherfucker.
Just a massive risk taking endeavor to
step in there.
Those two guys,
as big as they were in their prime,
those dudes were gigantic.
Pretty rough disco.
I think it was two rounds.
I think you knocked him out in a second.
Yeah,
if at the most.
It was the third,
but I'm pretty sure it's fuck is wrong
with Jamie.
Does your own bumps?
What were you looking for?
Trying to find which version of the
fight I was going to pull up.
What does it say?
What I started,
I'm pretty sure he knocked him out in
the second round if I remember
correctly,
but I might be wrong.
It might be the third,
but either way it was just chaos.
Now that I'm thinking about it,
thinking it was the third.
Tell us that too.
I'm trying to look for that before I
pull up the video.
Do you got a video?
Just throw the video on.
We'll figure it out when he gets knocked
out,
but I mean we had talked about Tommy
hearns the other day when Tommy hearns
knocked out Roberto Duran.
That was one of the most spectacular
knockouts ever.
Look at this.
Look at Tommy hearns was awesome.
He had a big crazy afro.
He had a back that was so wide.
It looks like he was a flying squirrel.
Like you could jump off a building and
sort of safety.
I mean,
he was so unusually built and he was
shredded too.
He was a.
He was built scary in a different way
and then hagler
he was the ultimate throwback.
I mean,
you're talking in the 19 eighties.
He was a throwback.
We,
they thought of him as a throwback in
the eighties,
like you thought of him the same way,
so he was 30 then,
which is kinda crazy because this is
like the tail end of the Haggar career.
I think haggard only fought is like 35
and then he retired after the sugar ray
Leonard fight.
But this was Hagler,
you know,
when he to agler this was 30 years old.
This is as good as it fucking guts.
Five foot nine,
160 pounds and just a fucking dynamo.
And you know,
the weird thing,
one of the weirdest things about Hagler
God are they still have watched that
dude five.
He had natural.
I'm like head gear.
He had really thick mode.
Look at that beautiful right hand.
These guys.
These guys are winging it at each other.
Oh my God,
this is crazy.
The thing about haggars,
he also could take a tremendous punch,
like a trim.
That exchange.
He was very smart,
right?
Yeah.
What was very composed,
but he had natural thick muscle all
above his ears.
Like his temple area was almost
protected by like thick muscle.
And I don't know what that's from,
whether it's like from some biting
exercises that he had done because there
was a bunch of guys who did have some
devices to strengthen your jaw.
And Gerry Cooney used one before he
fought George Foreman.
I remember seeing it.
It's like this thing you put in his
mouth and it was like a.
He would bite down on it and lift
weights with it.
So he's like pulling a cord and lifting
weights with his jaw.
Well,
I don't know if hackers was just natural
just born with it,
but whatever it was is you can kind of
see it in the shape of his head.
You see is right in this hitman's right
now.
He pops it right at him.
He steps to his left arm.
Just goes up like a short distance.
Fucking amazing.
Yeah.
Tommy hearns broke his hand somewhere in
the,
in the round.
And those fucking bombs.
You strong muscle head.
Sure.
You going to break something?
Look at this.
Well,
you throw full power bombs and hit
somebody in the top of the head.
Something's to go.
That top of the head doesn't move very
much.
That's where a lot of guys will break
their hands.
It's hitting guys on the forehead.
This is just a crazy fight.
The Marvin Hagler just absorbing it and
then he starts putting the pressure on
her and so we're like two minutes into
the round now and hearns is started to
throw weaker and weaker punches and now
haggars muscle and I'm up against the
corner and just beating them down.
That's one of the big things about
Hagler was his endurance,
his pace and just the will that he had
the will to fight a fight like this
where you just stand right in front of a
guy like Tommy hearns and said,
dude,
you are not going to knock me out.
You can't knock me out.
You don't understand.
You think you could knock me out,
but I'm going to stay right here.
Like nobody fought Tommy hearns like
that.
Everybody will want to stay the fuck
away from these punches with hagler
could absorb punches like almost like no
one else.
He got knocked down once and his whole
career and it was a bullshit knockdown.
The referee called it a knocked down,
but if you look at it,
it doesn't look like jet.
Most people agree that it wasn't a good
knock down.
I don't remember the fighter he fought
to.
I think it was one role,
Dan,
I'm pretty sure,
but it was more of like
he like Kinda shoved him down.
Then knocked him down.
You know when you was like Tommy hearns
and some other boxes like Roberto Duran
or something.
You could tell that they were raw talent
and walked into a gym and they worked
with somebody really good and they
learned how to box will.
I see Marvin Hagler and I see like the
guy you were talking about before,
that's 49.
I know floyd mayweather mayweather when
I watched them box.
I think that that's.
This is as good as it gets.
What I watch,
Floyd Mayweather.
What?
I just watched this fucking animal dude
was standing in front of them,
but as intelligent as a boxer can
because we all know if I throw something
that means I'm open.
He throw a lot being in front of him,
he's like sucking him men.
He's doing something to them.
Which is,
and this is what I see this now as an
adult,
you don't see this when you're 20
fucking through.
You just see stupidity.
But this is where I see his smarts.
He's fucking smart,
man.
Well,
he's also,
and Tommy,
he's doing of wisdom is something that,
I don't know,
I'm not a boxer,
but I could see that he's got a plan.
He's not like,
you know,
he's not doing a vandelay standing in
front of you.
You know,
he's,
he's very smart.
Fucking amazing.
When you watch this type of shit,
what you learn.
He was just such a pleasing boxer to
watch the way move to all that Bob and
weave in and head movement and you know,
Marvin had just that like track you down
style too.
Like you knew he was coming forward like
Marvin Hagler wasn't doing any fancy
foot work or you know,
doing the Ali shuffle.
He was moving towards you,
looking to break you.
Oh,
and those Mugabe's you mentioned.
And those other guys.
They were fucking killer killers,
killers explained boxing in those days.
It's Kinda today compare it to.
It's no comparison.
Look at this on the left and this is
where it starts coming on strong.
So I think we're in the second round,
right?
Right.
I think he stops him here.
I think if I remember the third boom,
boom.
And they stops him in the third or this
is the third.
Oh,
okay.
So this is where he starts hurting them.
Damn.
But he's got this number right,
because he's got his number and he's not
even going in like a savage either.
Again,
very composed.
Watch them again before this round is
over at each one of those types.
It's just cutting up the fucking tree.
Well he's not giving them any air
either.
Boom.
Those are the guys that don't give you
any breaks.
Those guys the scariest because you can
never recover.
So if a guy like Tommy hearns unloads
his best shit on you and then breaks his
hand.
So he's got one hand.
I don't know which one.
I believe he hurt his right hand.
So he's got a left hand,
his right hand is all fucked up and he
can't really knock you out with it
anymore.
He's fucked.
So now he's trying to kind of try to hit
you with big left hooks and Marvin never
let some stop.
Never let them take that breath.
Always keeps him moving,
always keep that pressure on him and
he's just wielding
where every second of every round he's
wilting.
And in these exchanges where it takes a
break,
you hit him with some hard shots and you
just keep piling it on.
Key.
Pilot it on.
That was an exciting,
exciting era of boxing.
You could wear his socks all the way up
to your knees,
get athletic socks with stripes on them
for these pay per view of as I used to
go to the metal heads.
Yeah.
So you would go to the meadowlands race
track and that would be inclusive in the
price of the fucking track that night.
What's the gamble?
What's the fight?
I forget who I saw Marvin hagler fight.
How many times are the haggler flight?
Tummy hurts just once.
Okay.
Tommy hearns didn't want no more of this
shit.
Who did is fight a couple times sugar
ray.
That's who I saw at the the boom,
the left hook.
Boom,
the right hand.
left hook,
right hand.
God Damn had Tommy her to survive this.
See now Marvin is pouring it on.
Look at this.
Jesus Christ.
Look at his hands.
Joe Rogan did.
He hasn't moved this beautiful.
Just beautiful,
beautiful box and look.
Same pace that he had in the first
round.
I mean mark was just beating down on
him.
Just putting it on him.
God is a great fight.
Such a great fight.
So yeah,
Tommy makes it out of the second round.
Wow.
See My.
That's one of those things,
man,
in your brain,
you have a memory and it's like a false
memory and sometimes you have to watch
the fight to see it because it's just
the case with everything though.
There's so many memories that you have
from just a few years ago.
You wonder like,
man,
how did that really go down?
Let me watch it again.
What was that movie really like?
Yeah.
Let me watch that fight again.
The human memory is real weird.
That's the saddest things about these
boxers too,
when they get older and older and more
fucked up.
As you know,
the memories.
One of the big ones that goes well,
that's one of the.
One of the things that I've heard you
talk about,
like let's say somebody has a fight on a
Saturday,
they have a close decision.
You'll watch it again Sunday when you
get home.
Then you will watch it for a few days,
let the eat to wear off and then watch
it again and you'll see the true winner
if you know how to count points and the
bullshit.
You know the problem with picking a true
winter though I,
I sometimes make subjective decisions in
my own head that go back and forth like
I'm not always convinced that I'm right
like you.
If you look at a guy who lands harder
shots but less of them,
like here's a good example,
Dan Henderson versus Michael Bisping.
Now Michael Bisping thinks he won and
the judges think you want,
and a lot of people think he won because
he landed more shots,
controlled,
more moments of the fight.
Dan Henderson thinks he won because he
hurt Michael Bisping a couple of
occasions,
beat him up.
His face was really battered and in the
first round in particular,
he came way closer to stopping the fight
then
than bisping ever did to him.
So I could see that argument as well,
that those moments where he had
incredibly damaged should be worth a lot
of points.
I see those arguments,
man.
I don't.
I don't know who's right or who's wrong.
Quite honestly.
I could see both arguments.
I see bisping's argument makes a ton of
sense to me.
He put in more work,
he landed more shots.
He,
he came back from getting really badly
hurt,
which showed amazing heart and cardio.
I see that argument too,
so it's like deciding who wins and loses
a fight isn't always very clear.
There's different philosophies like you
talked to a wrestler,
he's way more impressive.
The guy that takes the guy down a bunch
of times.
Then a guy who lands some brutal leg
kicks in the third round,
but if you talk to a Moitai Guy,
he'll go,
yeah,
well what happened in those first two
rounds?
Yeah,
he took me down,
but he didn't do anything once.
He had me down.
So the only thing is he's laying on me.
I'm not getting hurt,
but in that third round I fucked him up
and you listen to what he said and go,
wow,
that is a good point because that guy's
damaged like you damaged his leg.
Yeah.
There's the Kao Woo.
Show that again,
so that you're a barrage.
Wow.
This is 85.
Watch this shit.
God Damn Man.
Yeah,
I was in high school,
Dude.
This is when I was a senior in high
school.
This was a tough fight.
I remember watching this with my jaw
just hanging down like wow.
Because I thought it was going to be a
crazy fight and it was a crazy fight,
but I never thought it was going to be
this.
This was so crazy.
And Marvin Hagler just mauled him.
I mean,
he kind of shut everybody up,
man,
because there was a lot of people that
thought Tommy hearns going to knock them
out.
It thought that he had never been hit.
Oh,
so you went a little bit too far back.
This is where they checked his cut and
uh,
well they checked his cut.
They were,
you know,
Tommy hearns and nailed them a couple of
times and Hagler is probably worried
about them stopping the fight.
Was that just God knows what the fuck I
was doing.
I was in Jersey and hygienists.
I'm shit 85.
Tommy hearns had such a good job.
Just snap it out at you.
And what those long arms.
He used to keep his hand like below his
trunks,
you know,
like below the waistband of his trunks
and just pop it right in your face.
Like see how he did it there?
Oh Shit,
boom.
This is it.
Boom.
That lasts right hand.
And then that left.
Wow.
That was one of the greatest boxing
fights in boxing finishes of all time,
of all time.
Especially.
It's hard today to understand what it
was like when I was in high school when
this was going on because this was a.
It was just,
there was no internet.
Right,
so this is,
this is just word of mouth and radio,
you know,
you'd hear about it on the radio,
he'd see the newspaper,
you'd look in the box.
It was,
fuck yeah,
it was paper view and you didn't see
Dick.
You had to go somewhere,
you got to go somewhere.
He had to go somewhere and you had to
watch it in a theater.
We would pay it would,
they would call closed circuit closed.
They didn't call it paper view back then
you say,
oh,
well how do we see the fight?
Oh,
it's closed circuit.
So you would go there and you'd pay a
ticket and then you go sit in a movie
theater,
a bunch of other savages and you guys
would all watch the boxing match
together.
That's how I saw sugar ray and Hagler
close circuit.
I think I saw,
like I said,
I saw the haggler sugar ray at the track
and there was another one that I went.
It wasn't more like seats.
It was like general admission.
Yeah.
I saw it wasn't like seats.
I saw Tyson fight like that standing
room only and they put on this big
screen.
It was outside.
They put on a big screen and then they
played the commentary to the crowd was
crazy.
It was like a giant,
like almost like a drive in movie
theater,
but they had speakers and stuff that was
in vegas.
I fought Frank Bruno and uh,
they were fighting in Vegas,
but I didn't have the money for the
fucking tickets.
Tickets.
Stupid expensive thousand.
Tyson Tyson says prime and Frank Bruno
might've been the best built guy to ever
box heavyweight ever.
You ever see Frank Bruno?
Do you remember?
Jesus Christ last fight I watched Tyson
fight was maybe like when he knocked out
spinks.
Oh yeah.
The city.
My friend had a party,
you know,
the whole fucking first room,
the pizza them and get the.
I think Bruno was actually before
spinks.
Maybe I'm wrong,
I think I'm wrong.
I think spinks was first and Bruna was
later,
but um,
I'm,
I,
I don't know,
but Frank Bruno,
so just pull up a picture of him so you
could see them,
but you know,
you can see here from the fight that
dude was yoked,
but some pictures of Frank Bruno just
fucking ridiculous.
He's just act like.
And he was an argument that a lot of a
boxing trainers used to use that you
can't be that muscular and uh,
being effective heavyweight boxer
because he was.
So that's where Jones' son,
you're racist.
Jamie,
how dare you.
Who is that?
Oh,
how dare you.
It was Roy Jones,
but I'm like,
that's him now though.
See,
look how fat Ricky Hatton.
God,
Holy Shit.
Damn Ricky.
Um,
there's a good picture of two.
Dude was just jacked and that's him.
Obviously he's not even fighting.
There is like,
you just see without him even flexing,
like not at full muscle flex.
He's still super jacked
and he'd beat a lot of guys up,
but Tyson marked them.
But that again,
that was when Tyson was Tyson dude says
Tyson.
Bruno one.
I didn't know they fought twice.
Oh yeah.
I think he stomped him twice.
Let me ask you,
what year was this?
Just said it.
80 nine.
How was the testing in those days?
There was no gi test.
No.
That's why these guys showed up.
Fuck.
Like Ken Norton when I was a kid,
Ken Norton was the biggest motherfuck
have his own my life.
Was he bones at those times or was
Kennedy's natural,
do you think?
They did that in the seventies and it
was.
There wasn't a lot of options,
I think is steroids.
I like to check.
What were the options?
Maybe the Germans,
Adam,
they definitely had them.
The Germans had them.
There was definitely.
He just looks like an athlete.
You make an athlete there.
But there was one fight that Ken Norton
did look a little yoked.
Well,
he was a big guy when he fought Muhammad
Ali.
He broke his jaw.
I mean he was a serious athlete and he
was a former pro football player,
right?
Wasn't.
He says marine marine toughness.
And I believe Ken Norton Played
Professional Football,
so definitely did Sunday,
Sunday.
Is that what it is?
I didn't.
I just know that it's Sunday.
That must be what I'm thinking of.
But Ken Norton was a bad motherfucker.
Dude.
He actually got,
he's pretty badly banged up now,
but not from boxing.
He got in a car accident and apparently
got really hurt.
And that car accident,
did you see this over the weekend?
That happened in a box?
I did one mile one.
Well Lopez,
he take his code,
we're afraid of Alaska is junior.
And then when after his trainer punches
trainer in the face.
So that dude went down and then he goes
up to the guys trainer and I don't know
what the fuck the trainer said,
but he goes right out to them.
Do.
They're throwing bombs at each other.
Hilarious.
And that he's pointing at him.
Why are you pointing at him?
He started it.
Is that what you're saying?
God.
Craziness.
People are nuts.
But that's a nutty sport,
you know,
like what we were talking about earlier.
Would that,
uh,
hold floyd floyd mayweather thing like
that kind of sport.
You're going to have things like that.
You're gonna have people that want to
have 30 minute fights in the gym,
like 30 minute rounds.
It's pretty,
it's ridiculous.
But it makes sense when you think of
this sport,
you know,
what the sport really kind of
represents.
It's like the extreme nature of those
guys who compete in it.
It's just,
it's crazy that the athletic commission
got pissed at people throwing water
bottles but didn't get pissed at him for
doing that.
It's,
you know,
I get it.
If you're floyd mayweather,
I mean,
that's how you,
that's how you become that guy in the
first place.
You get brought up fate or there's talk
of him fighting Matt [inaudible]
supposedly according to,
um,
someone that I know that is not true.
How about that?
Alright,
well that's,
but they might be.
Who knows,
people might be trolling.
That might be a good fight though.
Fate and Mitzrian fate.
Orin car.
When I liked better in rising in Japan.
Jody,
Jodie,
jody.
I'm.
Tell me about Chicago last time I saw
fucking the Fado.
I love them to death,
you know,
I caught the tail end,
the fatal.
I quite like the two fights before
he got on board.
Right by a boy part first.
And you saw the fights that he won
before that?
Yeah,
like two fights and then a beat Brett
Rogers.
And then um,
I think the next fight after Brett
riders.
Pretty sure it was fair to him.
I didn't catch a fade or in his hay days
when I'm trying to say,
so the last couple of times I went,
it was like how people said they wanted,
they went to the checks at the end and
they got all excited and went down and
it was so that.
And then he got submitted by a for Doom
Vodoun which you and I discussed it.
This could fucking be doing them for
him.
And he's got a nasty a guard.
There's another guy we were talking
about yet.
Nasty guard.
Yeah.
So then I saw a couple of pieces of the
last fight that was fucking
embarrassing.
That was fucked up.
Both of them.
Fabio,
I love,
I love his fucking jaw and he takes a
fight at short notice and then he fought
that Indian gentlemen before that.
Yeah.
So,
but Fado,
I mean now you just want to exploit the
guy and that's how people get hurt.
I don't drink freight.
All wants to fight the people that he
for fucking years and he was killing
people and all of a sudden he didn't
fight for a while.
Now he wants to make a comeback.
I don't know.
His brother got out of jail.
His brother just got out of jail.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Okay.
I did read that.
Ready to fight.
I'm doing pushups and working out in
jail.
He's going to come out jacked new
tattoos.
I like.
He just wants to fight.
I want them to be able to fight just
like I wanted them to be able to fight
when he was 20.
I want to deal with the fight when he's
40,
if he wants to.
Why not mean he knows that it's not good
for you?
He knows that the damage that a fighter
can take.
He's been beat up.
He's been stopped.
Dan Henderson knocked them out,
bigfoot,
knocked him out for doom,
submitted by a triangle.
I mean he's had some goddamn wars and
some solid is fault.
Not only was he saw it as fuck,
he was solid as fuck in a division where
people are very rarely solid as fuck.
Like heavyweight is traditionally like a
division,
at least in the UFC where the title
changes real quick.
It's just,
it's too hard to maintain for whatever
reason or you know,
up until now it's been but fate or he
didn't.
I don't think he lost it anybody for
more than 10 years and years and he
fought very good fighters over there.
He fought very good fighters.
I mean he fought cro,
cop,
Cro,
cop.
You know when cro cop was streaking and
he,
he essentially out kickbox Cro,
cop,
you know what I mean?
That's what he did in that pride fight.
There was a lot of striking involved in
that fight and a fade or one he won that
fight like pretty clearly.
And again that was when cro cop was in
his prime and cro.
Cop had plenty of chances to stand with
them and he couldn't.
He couldn't get the deal closed.
So there was that fight.
That was a big fight.
Submitting Mark Coleman when Mark
Coleman was a fucking beast.
That was a big.
That was a big deal.
There's a few fights that were really
big deals,
but then there was a fight that didn't
happen.
Here's the biggest one though.
Minataro the Minataro fight.
When Tara was in his prime and fate or
beat him down,
that is probably is most impressive
because minotauro back then was fucking
scary.
He was really good.
I mean the minute that triangled Mark
Coleman Minute Toro,
that was just anybody,
he got a hold of your neck like you were
getting choked out,
you know,
he was,
he was bringing Jujitsu at a super high
level to the heavyweight division.
And the thing about minotauro was he
could take a shot.
He could take a shot,
especially in his prime,
like nobody.
He was like,
he was like,
I'm vulnerable.
I go,
he didn't feel pain.
You'd crack him.
He would take shots.
Then he'd finished you,
you know,
a cro cop beat the shit out of Minotauro
for one round.
I mean beat the shit out of him and then
he had kicked them at the end of the
first round,
like boom and minute.
Tarell thought they stopped the fight,
but it was actually the end of the
round.
He thought they stopped the fight with
the referee.
So that was like,
no,
like you're not going to stop this.
And the guy goes,
no,
no.
Just the end of the eyes like,
okay,
good segue around.
Starts shoots in,
takes Cro,
cop down,
armbars him.
He was just so tough.
Fade or beat him down,
man.
Fatal heart.
Beat him down and it was a scary beat
down.
Like he had been a when the corner and
he was ground and pounding them with
these for Roche's.
Those casting punches that fade orthros.
He's not punching like this,
like straight.
He's throwing these crazy like circular
hammers that are going around your
gloves,
like you're holding your gloves up in
front of yourself,
trying to defend yourself and he's
thrown these whipping punches that are
going behind the gloves and smashing
Minataro his face.
I was.
It was one of the worst beat downs you
ever saw.
A ground and pound and pride like
trapped in a corner because he just.
He just worked a man.
He didn't put some ferocious punches
then.
Not a lot of people would have been able
to take.
He broke his cheekbone.
He hit him with some bombs,
man,
but that was when Fado was fader.
So if you look at that fight with
Minataro,
you look at that fight with cro cop like
some of his best performances.
There's no doubt he's,
if he's not the greatest,
it's between him and Cain Velasquez,
in my opinion,
as far as the two greatest heavyweights
of all time.
And then honorable consideration to
fabrizio verdon like fabrice overdoing.
Despite getting killed with one punch by
steep meo chick still submitted.
Cain Velasquez submitted Minataro and
submitted fader.
He submitted three all time greats.
So those are the three that I think you
have to take into consideration is the
greatest of all time.
The only thing that you would look and
you'd say,
well more people.
Uh,
like how many people beat each guy,
you know,
how many people beat Minotauro versus
how many people beat fade or versus how
many people became.
And Kenny count all that up.
Who knows?
It's,
you know,
it's hard.
It doesn't really make sense.
Like trying to figure out who's the
greatest of all time,
who gives a fuck.
But if it is a moral new guy comes along
and we've been waiting some time for 20
minutes.
The thing about fate or those that he
did it for so long.
No,
he did it for the longest time when I,
I tapped into them,
like I said,
towards the end and when he lost,
he got the arm bar from reduce was like,
I wasn't surprised,
like you could see the deterioration
they were trying to explore them at that
time with the UFC that were asking for
money.
They know what they want to do with
them.
It was like they knew something.
You're following me.
It's like when that team calls you up,
when they try to give you the home run
fucking champion or the last eight years
miraculously on a Tuesday,
you know what I'm saying?
Like why do I deserve this fucking call?
They knew something and he started
losing a couple of fights and they
retired shortly after.
Well,
he lost three in a row.
It's really crazy.
Which was crazy.
And the first one he loses by
submission,
you know,
but it was a mistake.
He followed her doomed to the ground.
He hit him,
he had him hurt.
He thought he had him hurt him,
just set a trap,
locked them up tight,
gotten with that nasty yard.
But the second one was bad.
Second one,
he fought big foot and that was one big
foot was big foot.
That's been big for us on that
testosterone to they,
that's when they allowed them to do it
because you know,
bigfoot had a pituitary gland tumor,
so he had like legitimate gigantism and
he's a guy who actually needed
testosterone.
He really did need it and it was,
and a door,
it was just boom,
boom,
boom.
He stopped them and you know,
people forget that big foot despite the
fact that he's an enormous guy or I'm
not just despite rather,
but uh,
as well as being an enormous guy,
he's also a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black
belt.
Like legit.
That guy mounts you,
you're fucked.
It's a 300 pound giant person mounted
you with black belt skills and he's
dropping these fucking laptops on your
head.
Boom,
boom.
Yeah,
fuck that.
So that was a bad beating.
And then Henderson Kod and the Henderson
one was Henderson's and 185 pounds,
which is even crazier.
So he went from a 300 pound man,
k,
l and M to 185 pound man k on them.
And by the way,
Henderson not a big one.
80 five like Henderson's.
Not as big as some guys that have fought
and one 70.
That's how hard he fucking punches and
listens.
Tiny.
I wouldn't say that to his face.
I thought he was tiny,
tiny,
tiny.
But he listen man,
you know,
you watch pro football,
right?
You look at those defensive backs and
also you see him after the game and
you're like back,
I hate that fucking big way.
He's hitting,
he's lightened people up.
But he's five,
nine,
one 85.
The momentum's.
Wait,
you're right.
That's a perfect size for all that sharp
dig is Otros Cinco.
Check it out.
You.
Yeah.
You were just saying I'll look them up
as a fisherman.
I guess
six.
One,
one 85.
That seems like to be at your fastest.
Seems like that's a good weight for
those guys,
right?
Pulling 95,
two,
two.
Oh,
five one.
80 five.
You know,
if you're a good defensive back,
you're one 85,
you're banging up against my.
So what do you think?
Like the lightest guy that plays in the
nfl ways.
What's a super light guy?
One slash 75 with a DB.
Wow.
Let's check it.
I,
I gotta listen to this fucking there's
fucking receive is that'll pick you up
and throw you out of the stadium.
They got Thai.
Then instead of fucking six,
60 to 65 and they got,
you know,
what's the,
what's the shit they say to people like,
you know,
when they break up the 1:55,
look at this guy.
Oh my God,
what's the top at one?
19.
What's that?
That backup a little their backup so we
could see better.
It was from another story or didn't have
the whole thing.
Oh I see,
I see.
Huh.
But he's a receiver.
So one guy said he was one guy weighed
155 pounds.
Was that recent or is that back in the
day?
It was a current player.
That guy.
But let me tell you something about that
1:55.
That 1:55
is running fucking right.
Passion.
Probably I could bet my life that they
let him play at 1:55.
It's because either he's going to come
in one,
play a game and just do a for fucking
four for three.
Yeah,
there you go.
I don't have to tell you.
It's all the same shit.
That guy has to come in,
but if he gets hit he ain't get mad.
Don't get caught from behind.
If anything they like grabbed his leg.
The guy's gonna die like Pete rose.
Grab his leg there.
You ain't going to hit him.
It's just him doing drills.
Jamie,
you know,
what is he doing?
I want to say it.
Let's say a guy running for president.
Unless you're there,
I think there's something lost in a
video of a guy running.
You know,
what is it like you ever see a guy like
work out live and super impressed,
but you see it in a video and you're
like,
oh,
not that big a deal.
It's hard to move the ball back.
Yeah,
that's what they do.
And that's what I told you.
God for that Holy Shit.
Like lightning 56 is pretty fast from.
So Holy Shit.
Wow.
Well,
hey,
that's being 160 pounds.
Why he got them?
Watch this one.
Nope.
No,
this guy,
they said one 65.
So what they said Jamie is a different
guy.
Oh look at that.
I think I've tried to hit them.
They've tried to grab his leg.
Oh my God,
he's so fast.
That's hilarious.
Holy Shit.
He's like a ghost like to dive in in
front of them.
Look at this,
look at this shit.
Oh my God.
Best running back in college football
right now.
It's about his size.
He was a little bit bigger than 1:55,
but he's five slash seven,
like one slash 75 and he's got no,
he can't be stopped or stopped because
they can't see him.
What happened to that white dude right
there.
Back that up just a couple seconds ago.
I mean,
obviously I'm not a fucking commentary a
little bit for before that.
Before that.
Watch this guy.
Watch this white dude that's waiting
down there.
Watch this.
Don't do anything.
He's the punter.
He is.
He can't take them out if you're the
punter.
He's about.
Hold on.
Some part is don't give a fuck Jack.
They had a couple of cocktails before
the game.
They'll throw that shoulder in the but
that's all you're going to get out of
them as a good shoulder.
That guy just stood there,
so show that again.
That guy just stood there in front of
them and like fake them out.
Watch like he's running.
I was trying to steer him out of bounds,
but he can.
He can't tackle.
He doesn't practice to.
Can't tackle him.
He allowed like prop them up.
Well,
I don't have pads on.
Don't hit me.
Does the punter where the same pads?
Not usually because they have to kick
their leg up higher and they stuff on
Dev.
A smaller helmet to less protection.
Wow.
You really can't.
Weird.
You can't kick.
You can't touch the pump.
It's a violation.
So he's not going to be padded up until
the gazelles.
Right?
I get it,
but he could still trip this motherfuck.
I mean you get candies allowed to get in
300 g's a year.
You got to do something.
Do something.
Just kicked the ball into his hand.
He ran it back.
If he runs back to you,
you fucked up.
You fucked up.
You fucked up somewhere.
You put it in this range.
Trip him.
He see the punter.
What you want to do is.
Let's go to the fucking video tape here.
This is the scoreboard right here,
right?
Joe Rogan,
and this is the field.
If I'm a punk them my job is.
You see what that 60 yard line is?
Watches the punter punting,
hundred and 50 pounds.
That's the part that I just check that
dude.
Ninety nine.
Why that?
I think I get mad at them.
Elbow of them are.
They're excited.
They're happy.
Like you funny.
Like it was my daughters would think is
an aggressive,
you know,
like don't fucking hit me with guys
after they're playing football.
That's a good thing.
Booms.
He watched this other guy runs into
them.
You Washes?
Yeah.
Motherfucker like he's excited.
He likes double poms.
I'm on his chest,
but that's it because he likes him.
So Joe Rogan,
he wants to have the boy here right when
I'm paying you.
I don't want to.
Borderlands in here.
Yeah.
He's going to get momentum from here.
Right?
I want the borderlands always on the six
yard line right here.
This is why I want the ball on the end
territory.
Right?
Because I got more support.
I could get them from the inside.
This motherfucker kicked it here.
He's fucking doing a fight.
He's five foot 880 pound weight thing is
going to do.
Right,
so you kick a ball,
throw a guy right there,
you put it right there for him.
He should be shot on.
You should at least recovering tackle
them or buy them or do something.
Yeah,
already fucked up with the punter
already.
He fucked up.
You want to put that ball where he's
going to have the most out.
Let me ask you this.
When you're talking about baseball and
all the pete rose stuff,
you can run into dudes anymore and you
know you're seeing like the softening of
society.
How are they going to soften up football
they have.
You can't be an and no more like can you
go on to still pretty fucking brutal,
right?
The raiders,
you remember because at this time you
were a kid and people talked about the
raiders.
Had a reputation is bad motherfuckers.
I mean one of their guys crippled the
dude on Monday night football.
Jack Tatum fucking crippled the guy with
a hit home at first.
You know,
until the spine.
That's.
Did he do it on purpose?
I don't think so,
but that's the reputation you have is
that reputation has grown,
you know,
with all the Mattoon,
Zach's and all those crazy motherfuckers
hit themselves in the head with helmets
and Oh shit.
Does it sell tickets itself?
Tickets.
I mean now with all the show,
often,
I don't know.
It takes away.
I don't need to see a guy on his back,
bro with his parents and home on their
feet watching this on tv thing and his
body shaking because he just jolted his
neck.
I think that shit too.
Well,
I have a friend who went to a high
school game recently and he said,
I think he said five,
five kids got laid out in a high school
game.
He said they just cracked into each
other and you know,
seeing as kids lying on the ground with
their Bell Rung City saw it five
different times.
He might have said six man,
I'm,
I'm trying to remember,
but he was shocked.
Oh my God,
those two guys.
Oh my God.
They double smash into this dude,
look at this.
He gets the ball.
Boom,
boom.
Oh,
that guy's going home for a couple of
weeks.
It went back like that.
That's horrible.
Is that him?
No,
it's another guy.
It's like the top 10.
Oh,
highlight thing.
I was just putting it up.
I as you're talking.
I thought they're showing them smiling
afterwards like we're okay.
Everything's fine.
You fucking on that play.
Yeah.
You imagine your home.
It goes back that are looking at these
potential.
Is that a fine?
Is that a violation?
Jamie's going to be a.
because he led with his elbow.
He knocked him out.
Oh Shit.
On the replay here.
He's the guy that dove into them because
when the quarterback slides like that,
joe that aren't allowed to hit them at
all,
they're giving up their body,
so not allowed to be touched.
Basically.
Out All you gotta let them just hit the
ground and he was already flying in and
hit him with the elbow,
which also hit him in the head.
Say Probably.
He probably got fined 25,
30,000
bucks for this.
Wait a minute,
hold on.
Do that again.
Let me say this again.
The car,
he's,
since he's sliding feet first you got,
you don't even touch them.
You're supposed to just let up,
but he's.
He's already in a position where you
can't stop to it.
Too Bad.
You got to have better control you.
That's what they say.
You just kind of better control.
But what do you think?
I'm looking at this and it didn't look
intentional to me.
I mean elite.
You could definitely argue that it's not
intentional.
I mean it seems like the guy is sliding
and he's on top of him already.
He's got to kind of roll with it.
Do you think he knew that he was hitting
him in the face now?
One,
we were just literally just talking
about that specific one here.
You can see him throughout his elbow,
so it looks like he's doing a little bit
extra with the elbow,
but then they also,
they'll get into arbitration things like
they also do with some of the MMA thing.
They'll have a lawyers argue some of
this stuff out.
So what happened with that Tom Brady
situation at drug out for two years and
they finally just took us four game
suspension.
See,
I don't know man.
It's hard to say.
Now.
The problem we're having is Joe Rogan is
said,
okay,
I go back and I look at my high school.
I looked at the kids I grew up in those
four years.
I knew how they practiced.
I knew how they worked out and I knew
how they hit each other.
Okay.
And then some of them went on to college
and did what the fuck they had to do.
Are they any of them fucked up today?
Oh yeah.
What a troll.
That dude head to head Kale.
That guy.
What?
You know why five kids went on to your
friend's high school,
man.
You know why?
Why?
Because Oh,
Jesus.
Now were bread and butter in them.
And then show that one again and then
not used to get mad.
No more were bread and butter.
What do you mean?
We'll put down to that.
So he was at practice with just going
like this now,
which is going like this.
It's like when you and I go to a karate
competition and it's a
Oh,
oh,
oh my God,
this is horrible.
This one's horrible.
Boom,
look like his body goes backwards.
He's unconscious.
Oh my God.
Boom.
Has had.
Oh,
when the helmet goes off,
you know you're fucked.
That's visions.
That's Japanese people yelling at the
night.
That's what you hear in the middle man
out cold.
You need to be a parent watching this on
TV at any level.
No.
He's snoring out cold.
That is.
Look at this.
Could do all my
God.
He took it to the temple sideways.
Head to head.
Now,
that kind of shit.
Is that on purpose?
That's ahead.
That's flipped out.
He went,
yeah,
that was the shoulder.
That's.
That's kind of what you're taught.
That's what you're taught to do.
So just part of the consequences of
ball.
Big giant guys running around his
shoulders.
It hit him.
So I thought it was heading to work at
his waist.
Joe Romm back.
Look how everything twisted.
It's not just a head contact,
it's that spine contact.
That's what makes altogether.
You just see a fucking bolt.
The lightening and Shit,
look at that spine.
Can his whole thing twisted?
That's why he put his arms up.
Is that the guy that got knocked out
that was sitting there with the
dreadlocks?
No,
they were shitty editing this video.
They fucked with me twice.
I was going to show you next.
This is what the.
The alternative to this is right now is
there's some tackle non tackle nonpaid
leagues and so there's seven on seven
us.
There's less guys running.
I don't
know that anybody wants to pay to watch
this though.
This is the problem.
Well,
the idea is to be that haven't pads was
good for you and have it helmets is good
for you,
but now they're thinking that it's not
in that you're going to do things like
that where you wouldn't do those kinds
of things.
Going back to your fucking brain
argument brain,
if the brain doubled in 2 million years
or whatever,
the fucking thing.
Our strength also doubled.
The things that we're able to do with
our bodies also doubled.
Okay,
and even though you're a welcomed
addition,
football pain,
you're prepared for him.
It's like this.
You're not prepared for me if I'm
fucking dead lifting 70 slash 50 and I'm
doing certain exercises to make my hits
even better because there's some guy
like the guys we talk about like the
trainers is.
We talk about the working on specific
movements like they worked on specific
movements or have ema.
We were talking about like joy Alvarado
works on the,
the,
the Turkish getup.
Well that's people man.
When football that I've said,
you know what,
I've been watching football for 20 years
and this is the workout I'm implying and
this makes a guy like you at 20 fucking
22 years,
the strongest you've ever been.
Twenty four years out of college.
You're bench pressing 3:50
3:50.
Even if you're fucking one 85,
you're bench pressing now in highschool
3:25.
It's not what it used to be.
80 five,
the national average of this.
Go ahead and look at the results of
these combines 20 years ago,
30 years ago,
and what these kids are doing now.
Speed wise,
strength wise,
flexibility wise.
So there's a guy that has broken down
the kinesiology of a football hit.
Okay,
and then maybe put it in a workout.
I'm hitting you double than what I used
to hit you all.
Nine hundred and 30 pound squat by a
Texas high school junior.
This is what I'm talking about.
That's a junior in high school.
They've improved form.
They've improved seven foot 440 pounds.
Okay.
You know,
grow big and okay.
Fifty years ago or seven foot guy
couldn't walk around.
Okay.
Now he's playing basketball.
He's adjunct for years or seven foot
guy.
Couldn't put weight on there.
That fucking kid.
Look at this.
The biggest football player we've ever
seen.
Wow.
He's in high school.
He's gone.
Yeah.
That bringing them cars already.
Oh yeah.
His bitches.
That bringing them women in a car trunk
prepared already.
We guys are going to shoot them and put
them in the trunk and say,
we'll see.
I'm bringing him.
Young tech has to be the mountain for
Halloween,
right?
No.
Why would you be anything else?
I would have fucking armor.
Just different different outfits at the
mountain.
Where's done?
Just like the brain has grown.
We've gotten stronger.
We've gotten way stronger.
Our,
our workouts were particular things have
gotten more on that.
Was that
what you want pinpoint for what you're
doing or what exercise will they
understand what's beneficial and what's
so?
They also understand when you're
recovering epogen and guess what?
In 20 years we're going to be hitting
even auto.
You're going to see jaws flying right
off the fucking face.
Some MMA fight.
You're going to see a George just snap
open to the whole of the side of some of
these that somebody is going to be
hitting that much fucking harder.
You know,
30 years ago,
look at this,
you know,
they were hitting in the seventies,
but.
Well,
it's interesting to me is when you start
talking about the brain getting bigger
and bodies faster,
kill him.
That dude was a killer.
There was accounting straight up.
What's interesting to me about these
athletes getting better and faster and
stronger and brain's getting bigger.
It's a wonder what it's going to be
like.
You know,
they talk about the human brain doubled
over 2 million years.
Why would we assume that that stopped?
You know,
maybe it's just a long,
long,
long process of brain getting bigger,
people getting bigger,
people getting strong or people getting
faster.
Like what's the performance of a person
that don't look like if it's increased
that much.
It's the 19 sixties.
Have we reached like this?
A bottleneck,
like a physical bottleneck and we'll be
able to fix that with like genetic
engineering will know that.
No.
Now we're just going to.
Now we're pointing.
I'm being even stronger and faster
though.
Yeah,
I know,
but just like this is where you saw to
that that whole side thing gets real
interesting.
You know,
and they're,
they're doing a noble pursuit,
right?
They try to clean up the game,
stop all the cheaters,
people getting pop left and right.
I go on the underground,
the underground new section that mixed
martial arts.com
and like every couple of days some new
persons flagged you find out this guy
got flagged that kind of got flagged.
So they're catching people for sure,
but what are they going to do?
What are they going to do when,
when science starts stepping in and
improving people.
You know,
I mean it seems to me like it's pretty
fucking inevitable.
I mean right now in mixed martial arts,
let's just take the USC for example.
If I was a manager,
I'd tell my client,
listen,
I don't give a fuck what you're
thinking.
Please don't embarrass me.
Don't you have a fighter's?
Don't want to be honest about that kind
of shit.
I know.
But you know what?
As a man to man,
you might be on this time.
Yeah.
I don't want them motherfuckers with
them.
Yeah,
I think I catch you at the time when you
don't need it.
You know,
it's interesting.
Apparently they don't know how to spot
human growth hormone very well.
It's speculative whether or not they
could catch people doing that and it
might be one of the reasons why they're
holding pis and blood for so long.
They hold your sample for like nine
years.
They freeze it.
So as the tests get better and better
and better,
they pull things back and then the,
you know,
if you're still competing,
if I can find you and suspend you five,
six years from now,
that is the fucking Kinky Shit.
You're gonna hold my pis for nine
fucking years.
What type of Freaky motherfucker you pop
in there?
Well they already got rid of two Olympic
gold
medalists from Russia to wrestlers in
2008.
They both are pissed positive for
something where they tested negative.
Then they held onto their sample and now
the screening has gotten much better and
they just caught them.
They removed their gold medal to Olympic
medalists.
Gold medalists have no fun,
no studs to you look at them.
You're like,
how's that guy on steroids?
She just assumed these Russians,
man,
they have a different thing going on
over there that's state sponsored.
No one's trying to cover that up.
Felt like they,
they just,
that's what they do.
Like that's one of the reasons why they
came back close to getting kicked out of
the Olympics in Rio.
Like they were talking about kicking the
entire Russian team out of the Olympics
as like,
you fucking people have state sponsored
doping and I think their eyes,
it's like everybody's doing it.
Fuck it.
Let's just do it the right way.
So they just grow you into a certain
age.
You get to a certain age,
your body,
but not.
Let's say you would get to a certain age
and you're a wrestler at a certain days.
They just make you go somewhere.
It's like Cuba.
I think there's probably no,
no,
there's a lot going on there.
And you go somewhere and the doctors
checked you out and they give you shots.
They tell you their vitamins don't tell
you everything that you fucking,
uh,
which this guy is another one.
This is one of them.
Two wrestlers.
Oh,
this guy got stripped of a bronze medal.
Another guy gets tripped the,
if it's state run,
they level with you and it's Russian.
They've only been level with you.
Which uh,
which date,
what date is this?
When did this article come out?
Jamie?
Is it a reason?
Anyway,
point is 2012.
Yeah.
There's two guys that they just did it
too from the 2008 Olympics and there,
I'm pretty sure they were both gold
medalists,
but uh,
you know,
it's like we were talking about with
Usada earlier.
So it's,
it's a weird business man.
Weird business.
Pino fighting's a weird business.
That's why,
you know,
you look at that Floyd Mayweather,
Jim fight thing you like and no one
another sport would they make you have
like a basketball game to the death,
like no time moments,
no score in points.
He just,
just rack it up.
Just keep going.
And know there's periods like everybody
plays by the rules,
not boxing,
like it's a compelling thing to have a
30 minute round.
You could die doing that kind of shit.
Like that is how people that,
how that shit gets exposed for real.
He's illegal magnet.
They tested comedians.
Oh my God.
Drug tested comedians.
Like certain chains,
like the Improv or the punchlines like
chains at La.
Five clubs said,
listen,
we've got a drug test you a week before
you come into our club to make sure
that,
you know,
can you imagine that ridiculous for that
we got the entity level.
So like this.
I'm not even worried about me,
I'm just saying,
you know,
just the general.
I'm worried about you really.
You're not worried about me.
Fuck though.
If they started testing for drugs,
I'm not worried about you.
I'm terrified for you.
Just smoke reefer.
That's it.
Yeah.
But that's a drug.
What are you going to do?
It was like ups would if like a God.
Honestly,
you know,
what could have happened.
Okay.
You know what could have happened.
They,
all they would have to do is say
something like,
uh,
like maybe someone was really high and
they were on stage and they said
something really ridiculous and the club
got sued and so they'd say we now have a
no marijuana policy because the guy was
on that fucking devil's cabbage.
And he said some ridiculous shit and our
club got sued.
That's all it would take.
I felt like one big chain,
like maybe Yuck Yuck or the Improv or
something like that.
They just decided,
uh,
we do not care what you do in your own
time,
but we require when you work for us that
you have a marijuana metabolite level of
less than whatever the fuck it is.
So all right.
They would test you when you got the
town or the jet after tests you
beforehand.
So we just show up at your house.
Like you saw it a week before you got
the Gig.
They show up at your house,
like you saw them and then once you get
there they're going to test you again.
Or do I have the whole weekend to get
one test you again at the end of the
week to just turn their laws?
Those tests are expensive.
Are they the other pot ones?
Like from quest diagnostics.
That's like a thousand bucks I think.
Which one is the one over the counter at
all?
You go to quest diagnostics.
Different.
That's the,
that's what I'm thousand users.
Right?
Protest this guessing you're going to
cost me two grand just to come into my
fucking clubs to make sure the Improv
doesn't get sued.
Sir.
And you've said,
you've said you've said some very
defamatory things in the past about
Mother Teresa.
What'd you think about a year and Piss
test?
100,000
dollars a costs your company and it's a
very controversial man.
Joey Diaz and the business that we're in
here at the Improv is providing with
families,
families with laughter.
Okay.
Some of the things that you've said,
you know,
quite honestly I,
I believe in freedom of speech,
but I find it offensive.
No.
Okay.
So now we got nowhere to run,
but to go to the rock clubs
and do comedy.
Well,
when you go to the rock club then it's
cool because you're,
you're,
you're in Japan.
That's like,
stand up to fight the Japan.
Fuck it.
I'll fight Japan.
Fuck you motherfuckers.
Hey you coming in on this.
I'm a election night thing that Stan
hope and I are doing.
I don't know.
You said some day.
It's like a live part.
We're just gonna hang out.
Where in the main room in the main room
we're gonna do is we're going to look at
the results.
We're going to have like a laptop or
something,
streams or results,
and we're gonna.
Just talk some shit while the elections
going on.
Most likely
it will have nothing to do with the
fucking election dog.
Yes,
please.
You know I'm a criminal.
Yes.
And happened.
No,
I can't vote,
but that Hillary is a criminal.
Well,
they did reopen the investigation into
her.
Even that stuff.
She's been a criminal for fucking 20
years.
Trump ain't no better or in a bad
position.
Again,
I got no dog in this fight.
This is from an FEC.
Who Do you refer out of those two?
I really wanted Bernie Sanders to come
back.
I don't know.
Bernie was the best choice,
but if we could keep them around for
three years shooting fucking good
president,
like something pops up.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we shoot Bernie Sanders.
If they shot Bernie Sanders,
he would be.
I've just heard a.
I read some New York Times thing about a
week ago about arms that are Clinton
foundation soul.
Well,
it's not,
it's not that direct.
It's a very complicated.
As people who were donors to the Clinton
Foundation received deals.
This didn't.
My men Ollie North get in trouble for
shit like this.
Know Ollie north got in trouble for.
They were.
That was when the sandinistas were
fighting the contract.
They were shipping arms illegally to
those people.
They're providing arms.
These emails about arms,
right?
I don't know what the emails are king,
but uh,
there's a lot of them.
30,000
emails that got deleted after a
subpoena.
And you know,
the crazy thing is people talk.
One of the weird thing that's going on
with this election is that everybody
loves that.
A woman,
like they're looking at the bright side
of things,
right?
Trying to look at the bright side.
It'd be live with fucking fat and it's
not going to be the whole little fucking
fat chicks would get tos and bare feet.
That wedge bag is 180.
All right.
She's going straight to the clutches of
Hell.
You understand me?
Straight to the clutches of how crooked
husband the night she gets into the
White House,
the lights will all turn red.
Oh my God.
You'll hear like say tannic music
playing and trump ain't no better.
But you also got to remember one thing
about this fucking moron.
Okay.
Because I've been thinking about it from
an objective point of view.
I'm no fucking Phi Beta kappa.
He's not a politician Bro.
He was never really a politician.
I may not even be encouraged to do
something like this.
So the shit he's talking about grabbing
people's policies.
The thing that pissed me off the most
about that shit,
you know,
many times I've seen a woman with a big
fucking 60 pound monkey me when I'm
outside and I just said to myself,
I would grab that motherfucker right
now,
but when I was a sophomore in high
school,
I had this Italian girl in my class that
will clogs.
She was a little on the heavy side,
but she was beautiful.
This girl could stop a fucking clock.
She was so beautiful,
but her little monkey weighed like 70
pounds and she was a sophomore and she
sat behind me and I just went to school
with just the look at her monkey.
I didn't give a fuck about the rest of
the day.
I didn't even.
I haven't even seen the vagina at this
time,
but through her fucking pants.
You had to see this fucking monster.
Why she walked past you with it?
Here we go home.
Me and my buddies.
Decorations and senses.
When you're close to him.
My buddy stinky would collaborate.
Did you see a?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I saw it.
Right.
That means when a pussy look like,
like right to the jeans.
It was just a mountain.
It was just a fucking mountain.
Wow.
And I remember her walking by me going,
what would it take for me to have the
balls to just grab it and just hold onto
that savage for a minute because it was
beautiful.
But the difference.
How old were you?
13.
11.
He was 60.
Oh,
okay.
I get it.
Oh my God.
You know
billy bar was on.
I was actually on his podcast the other
day and we were talking about it and you
know,
we're,
we're saying we've heard worse,
we've heard worse from friends that are
trying to make each other laugh and
you're saying,
shit,
that's not true.
And I said Joey Diaz would say something
way worse than that.
And will he be crying?
Oh my God.
Doesn't mean that you're out actually
grabbing girls pussies.
But you would say them,
I'll,
I'll fuck her feet looked like mine will
fucking stab a.
like you would say something like,
you know,
you know.
Yeah.
That was someone I told Sam that Sam
trip,
the other guy.
Steve Simone.
You see that girl?
How old are you?
40 eight.
I'm 53.
You're never going to see that.
Very good.
Have you ever seen like a nice looking
couple now?
Like he's 26.
She's 22 and that both beautiful.
She got perky little pits.
She's banging.
I was so legs are Sunday.
You think that the use of this little
young savage must be going home?
Tara,
that pussy that,
when you think back to your little 26
year old in the afternoons,
you can take them home and rub him down
and give them a good stab.
You come like three times the whole
fucking thing.
That never happens.
No more.
Like at this age,
you look at that and go,
I don't know if that happened.
You would think of that.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They all these guys like,
look at that young girl.
Look,
I'm gonna.
Go look at it,
look at it.
That'll never happen again in my world.
However,
I will never see a woman naked like that
ever again.
Let me tell you a story about my friend
Jay.
My friend Jay has a,
a friend who's a Texas oil millionaire.
Like he bought a ranch.
He bought a,
a hunting ranch,
like to go hunt deer on it.
That's all he does guys.
Sixty two guys.
Never had a kid.
Okay.
And uh,
I think he's been married and divorced.
Maybe never married.
Might be never married,
never had a kid,
doesn't give a fuck.
Like literally doesn't give a fuck.
And he,
every couple,
you
know,
however long it takes,
he's got some new 24 year old perfect
girlfriend and he just buys them a bunch
of Shit,
take some places.
And then eventually like,
I can't do this anymore.
He's like,
well,
you all take care.
And he just goes and gets him another
one.
And he's like,
I want you to come meet the new one.
But this guy is the quintessential crazy
Texas oil man.
So this guy goes to Africa and uh,
and he goes,
what'd you do over in Africa?
Goes on,
Shit.
We went hunting.
He go,
well,
what'd you shoot?
He goes,
Noah's Ark,
two of everything.
So it just shows up.
He stayed over in Africa for a month
just shooting things with this 24 year
old girl.
He was banging Jose Sixty two.
He had um,
he had a bunch of different bypasses
too.
He's had more than one by heart bypass.
Like he's fucked.
Like he's,
he ain't got much time left in.
This guy is just poverty and own woo.
I think if I saw a push a younger than
30,
I would have a bypass.
Right?
Right there.
My heart would split open.
I don't want to see it.
I don't like.
I don't.
I'm done.
I'm bored.
Where would you have the energy to keep
up with that?
No.
Twenty two year olds that want to fuck
like rabbits.
You don't have mortgages,
you know?
I mean I have to do is be awake when you
show up for work,
so that's your responsibility when be
22,
unless you fucked up horribly and gotten
yourself into some,
some real serious position of
responsibility.
But most of us are 22.
No,
barely show up for work.
If you've got fired and trying to get
another job anyway,
you're already thinking about quitting.
So when you're home,
when you're home with some girls also
22,
you got just too bizarre.
Just chewing up a piece of wood.
It's chaos.
Just chopping through your own young.
Just trying to get rid of come.
It's crazy.
I would never happen again.
Well it might,
but it's not gonna happen in this life.
No.
It might happen all over again.
I don't.
Like I said,
I don't even want to see a vagina if
it's under 40 anymore.
We've given me a heart attack.
I don't meet that my life.
You don't have been thinking about a lot
lately.
Why so many cultures?
Think about reincarnation.
Why so many cultures believe you do this
over and over and over again.
Why so many people think you come back
so you know the,
the,
the idea that we live and we die.
That's what.
That's what like someone who's an
atheist,
once you believe you're born and you die
and they might be right.
I don't know who's right or who's wrong,
but it is kind of fucking weird that so
many different cultures have this idea
that you live again.
What have you just keep doing this?
Would that freak you out?
Like I'm enjoying life,
right?
But why is,
why is the prospect of doing this over
and over again forever?
Like what if you had to live your
childhood like your childhood?
Joey was a very tumultuous
and crazy fucking childhood,
but it made you,
you.
If you knew that you had to start all
over again and you're gonna,
you're gonna,
close your eyes for the last time and
you're going to wake up in that hospital
room,
North Bergen,
New Jersey,
or in Cuba,
and you can do the whole thing again.
Same Way,
same way.
Oh my God.
You gotta get it,
right.
You're dealing it with variations.
So come back like as a bird this time,
that's what they do.
They fuck with you for a couple of times
that bring it back as an alligator.
You get run over in Florida.
Then they bring you back as a bird,
like a parakeet when the cat gets you
and then you come back as a human.
Yeah.
And then you start all over again.
Then there's times in your life where
you think,
I've been here before.
I've seen this before.
Like I've something.
And so that's what I feel about
reincarnation.
I don't know.
It's.
I've been at places and I've gotten.
I've been here before,
but then again,
you have to think about what scientists
believe.
That life is just an illusion that the
patterns that we see are just graded our
mind.
Who the fuck knows I'm having a good
time to refill.
Calms me down.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
What else we're doing comedy.
What?
Healthy.
We're having fun.
Still fucking ear or picking up the vine
like,
you know guys have come and fucking gun,
you know.
Oh yeah.
So how lucky am I think I'm going to sit
here and think about fucking going to
Mars with Elon.
I'm not sure.
Is that his name?
Eland.
Eli Musk.
That's my dawg dude.
We've known each other for almost 20
years.
Twenty years.
Has It been 20?
It might be 20 this giant this January
I'll be in La for 20.
Which means I met you march of next
year.
I got.
I became,
I got,
I landed in La January 20th and you know
I was a regular at the store.
February 19th.
Wow.
My birthday.
That was my only ever claim to fame in
this town.
I was here.
Stan hope referred me.
I did seven.
She told me come back next week and she
made me a regular.
It was like written in the movie.
I showed up at the comedy store up
Monday night at 1130 and 11 slash 25.
I think Griffin said,
do you mind if I do 10 minutes in front
of you and that was my comedy store
debut and Shit.
Like how much time did he do?
He went right to attend to.
He would do like three hours.
He would do three fucking hours,
but still.
That was a.
that's what kept me here was that stupid
fucking comedy store brother.
How great is that?
That I just walked in there.
Stan hope I kept.
I'm introduced myself to Scott Day.
Stan Ho said to me,
it's a six week minimal.
Wait,
I called in for you.
I had three people calling for me I
think and he was one of them.
They believe Stan hope the most and they
called me on a Friday though.
I said,
you're going up in front of Mitzi Sunday
at nine,
whatever.
I have three minutes ready.
And I was like,
what the fuck?
I thought I had to wait til April.
Wow.
Like no,
there was an opening on the list.
Go down there.
We've seen a lot of guys come and go.
You ever go down the.
One of the cool things about the comedy
store,
one of the coolest things is that the
walls are like a museum,
like literally like a comedy museum.
There is no comedy museum,
so for us,
the comedy museums of the wall,
so places like the punchline,
you know,
like when you go to an older club,
Nashville's Zania Zania national best
example pictures that'll make your jaw
drop.
Yup.
People that aren't even alive anymore
and people are not.
People that were really big and they
just stopped.
Tom Models is a one night or out of
Iowa,
like when you go to rooms and Wyoming
cribble runs,
which are one nighters that's different
than a station.
Every comedy club for people at home.
That means that a bar with a certain
town just does comedy on Tuesday nights
every night.
I went to a place in Riverton,
Wyoming and they had pictures of
Roseanne and Tom,
Roseanne and Tom Arnold together.
When they first started going on the
road together,
like he had the business for a long
time,
that's when they're out of Denver,
out of Denver,
Minneapolis.
I thought she was married to somebody
else and then they got a divorce and she
left and I think she went to Minneapolis
for a while.
I toured with them and uh,
wow.
You know,
that's one of the sad things about when
a comedy club closes down,
you lose that museum.
Like they used to be.
The last stop in river oaks had pictures
of Stan hope when he bad long luxurious
hair.
Remember when Stan hope had like fabio
hair stand hope.
He used to wear an overcoat and he had
long hair and I remember like,
I think I had heard that he didn't even
have a place to live,
just like a car got broken into the
finals of the San Francisco comedy
competition.
Overfilling.
And he went and bought like a secondhand
suit and he went back there and smoke
everybody with the suit on his shit.
Yeah.
That's where a Dane Cook's manager tried
to psych him out before he went on
stage.
What did he say to them?
Something Dickie,
you know,
something Dickie like,
you're never going to beat him or
something like that.
Like something really shitty stand
helpline of winning and crushed it.
I saw his son at that time was fucking
amazing.
Gyro and he's amazing now is set.
At that time he had,
he had connected the bridge from me.
That's what put me on the right path,
the bridge of when I watched what he was
doing in the half hour that when he was
headlining his first half hour,
then just the way he was delivering it,
his presentation when he was young at
the audience when they walked,
it was all a fucking thing of genius.
It,
it hit me so hard that I didn't do
comedy for about four days to gather up
like what am I going to do with my life?
Because if I'm not that good,
it's not,
we're doing this shit.
You know?
At that time he was doing the bucket of
Vaginas,
joke,
some way to come up to him and asked him
if he wants to buy a bucket of roses and
a bar.
I don't need roses,
I need a bucket of vaginas and then the
lady would walk out,
but I'll never forget that he said that
what?
I read the back of the class because she
walks out and then some lady in the
audience actually gets up and walks out
and he's like,
lady,
I'm sorry I should've said this one
online.
People would walk and then he'd say
things to them as they were walking out,
but it was so brilliant.
The people couldn't take it no more.
I loved what he was doing on stage.
He was talking about going to a bar and
the g string was stuck in the girl's
fucking thing and it was in there
somewhere.
I'm not doing any justice to this.
It didn't matter what he was doing on
stage.
Nobody was really doing at that time and
then he came to La and the way that they
were trying to make that fucking squeaky
clean,
squeaky clean,
and he went in and I was in the night
when he insulted the burn victim,
pick people up there.
The Guy,
he goes,
what the fuck you people depressed?
This guy hasn't cracked a smile and now
you know,
I mean,
he didn't stop for awhile.
Then he started walking the Improv,
you know,
like on those nights where all the
professionals and the Egos,
you know what I'm saying,
they would put him on and they would pay
and then Mitzi shore made a mistake and
she started putting that motherfucker
before betsy sokolow.
That's not a mistake.
It's a mistake.
Was she had a method.
She enjoyed watching that show.
But once you watched it at that time and
you know,
I'd tell you how it is to show opens up
at what time at the comedy store and
Saturdays 8:30.
In those days she will put Doug Stanhope
one third and then he would be,
he would hit so hard in the original.
They would see who first political guy.
Then they will have a buffalo and she
didn't really know who stan hope was.
She had forgotten and she put them up in
the,
the fucking nine.
You know,
the third guy on the list on a Saturday.
They were not ready for him.
I remember one particular Saturday he
was talking about lesbians with a Dick
Pumps and a softball game where they all
had.
I mean he was just going off and the
original room didn't even know where he
was going,
like nobody knew he was going,
you're a fucking lesbian softball
player.
You probably in the fucking thing with a
Dick pump,
and he even made a cover.
He's got an album cover dick.
That was that bit.
They want to fucking.
I'm sitting back there stone to the
Gills confused.
They were out of it,
but the saddest thing,
Joe Rogan,
honestly,
it wasn't the guy that him.
It was the two people that follow stand
up in those days were in a lurch because
the second guy that followed Stan hope
was all fucked up.
He just put bad energy,
general bombs in those days.
Hollywood wasn't ready for staying at
home and I saw it.
I saw that the Security Council approach
to stand up,
the Hollywood approach,
the stand.
I was changed like he used to be.
You know,
there were,
there were all boards.
They had a letter send down.
That's what happened.
Well,
they were all had 11 sitcoms,
you know they will.
Yeah,
because people will funny.
we can name a lot of.
We could sit here for two fucking hours.
We may have a lot of people that came to
this town who would genuinely funny and
then some fucking suit got to him and
said,
listen,
you have to write your Sitcom for these
people and talk about your stage
persona.
And then they went up there and change
that whole stand up and you know what?
That's funny in a way,
but it's not really who to fuck you up.
Right.
And that's what happened.
People got away from that for a few
years are years 96 to 2004 people got
away from that.
People still want you to build a sitcom
on stage,
but when that fucking idea went awry,
they hadn't.
They hadn't let fucking people with a
little crazy and it seems like the
podcast era.
Then people got to understand how much
entertainment there is.
Just people being themselves,
just crazy people.
People like you or people like already
or people like a Dunkin started.
People started recognizing that when you
let a guy just be himself or a girl just
be themselves,
you're going to get the real thing.
You're going to find out what's actually
funny.
Well,
it really makes you realize is how much
media does control what you watch and
see whether it's music.
It's comedians.
Let's pretend the,
but there was no venue for standup like
that except for Hbo.
Let's pretend that right now,
podcasts would not have come up in this.
In the last 10 years.
You would know me.
You wouldn't know Stan Ho.
No,
you wouldn't know.
Stan.
Hope you wouldn't know are.
You wouldn't know Duncan.
You wouldn't know a half a fucking
decent comics that are floating around
because the people who are controlling
comedy,
uh,
controlling comedy due to certain
criterias,
youth age,
it all has to mix up.
It all has to mix up.
If it doesn't make up and I'm not crying
fucking Wolfie I,
I,
I'm happy with the fuck I'm doing.
I've done great compared to what I
thought I was going to fucking do.
So I'm talking about,
uh,
sometimes I'll call somebody and they
go,
no,
you're too old for this thing.
Well,
you got to think about what people are
watching.
What can a guy like you to do?
You could do one or two things.
You can either do an hbo special or you
can do nothing.
You don't have uncensored radio.
Back then they didn't even until series
came along and Xm,
you didn't even have a venue on the
radio,
so you had nothing.
You had nothing to be you and your
stories and all your craziness where
you're free like this.
And so it wasn't a product to sell.
There was no pulse.
There's no market.
So unless you became a Kennison or a
dice clay or someone who got an hbo
special or a gut on Rodney Dangerfield,
hbo special with the world got
introduced to you being dirty,
no one was really going to buy it.
There was nowhere bitch we got on Joe
Rogan's podcast,
motherfucker,
you're the new fucking run.
You also have fucking Comedians to these
people.
They would never even dreamed about
going to watch who.
I remember years ago when we went up to
fucking cops,
the dude,
man,
I,
that shit used to bother me because that
was how we were viewed as,
well,
they didn't,
they didn't respect you guys know,
but in they thought because you guys
didn't have tv credits and because you
were dirty that uh,
you know,
I was making a bad choice by bringing
you with me.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
These guys are hilarious.
That stuff is fucking tremendous.
Amazing.
Fucked up.
I didn't bother now,
although some people probably St Joe you
were quietly.
No,
I blacked out for a while.
I went deep is a lot in that.
I took 10 fucking thing.
He did a podcast with Sam Harris.
Ten 10 sprays.
Took two before I got here too.
But I think those are kind of worn off
and I decided to just see what happens.
We know what's good about this.
You don't,
you don't go deep for eight hours.
No.
The other shit,
I got to commit to it.
I liked this little sprayer.
I just look for when it.
That was a little fucked up.
I ain't gonna lie to you.
I was seeing doubles.
I thought about taking a nap.
Well,
I think easy in.
Easy out,
right?
Because like it's not digesting in your
stomach.
It's going through your bloodstream
because you're doing it,
you know,
Trans Dermal.
Was that what it is?
What is it called when you put it on
your.
A subdermal right.
That was good there for a moment because
I hate that fucking bob before I came
in.
Oh,
you did that too.
How dare you?
Why not?
Why?
Yeah,
why not?
I got to dress up like a fucking
counseling lingual.
Thank you sir.
I got to dress up like a cowboy jack.
I'm excited.
I don't know what my wife's going to be.
She's trying to the baby.
Don't be an Indian.
People get mad at you.
Cultural appropriation didn't know what
the fuck's her name.
Have to apologize.
Hilary Duff.
Didn't she apologize for Halloween
costume?
That was cultural appropriation.
What was her costume?
She was a pilgrim and I think the second
lesson.
So you can't be an Indian.
No more.
No more Indians.
No more cowboys and Indians.
Cowboys versus cowboys.
And if you do encounter an Indian,
he better be an actual fucking Indian,
not some culturally appropriating cis
gendered white piece of Shit.
Hilary Duff is so sorry about her
offensive Halloween costume.
Oh my God.
So the man you see,
people haven't gotten the full message
yet from the social justice warriors.
They haven't gotten the full message
yet.
You're not allowed to wear that.
Indian social justice warriors fill me
in on this.
Social Justice warriors are people that
want to control the way people behave.
They want everyone to be very
progressive and very pieces that were
page and no now to just a group.
And we're going to enforce cultural
appropriation.
No white guys with dreadlocks.
Stop it.
Stop.
No,
you can't have taco Tuesday piece of
shit.
It's cultural appropriation.
They get mad if white guys cooked
Chinese food.
It's like there's so much going on.
I get mad of white guys because I know
why the Chinese guy cooking the Chinese
for that.
That's what's wrong with fucking thing.
That's true.
You know what else I demand for the most
part?
I like Mexican food from Mexican
people.
Um,
there's a guy that was getting in
trouble for cultural appropriation
because he was,
he ran a Mexican restaurant,
he's a white guy from Oklahoma and it
was a huge stinker through and
apparently this guy's a huge fan of
Mexican cooking and is a real like
master chef and goes to Mexico and
studied under the great Mexican chefs
and opens up Mexican restaurants in
America just because he loves Mexican
food and they're like,
fuck you.
You're not Mexican.
You can't do it.
Culture appropriation,
fuck away.
We're apologizing for Indian costume
before I go right now because I want to
turn on three is I'll tell you what's
the best show I've seen the sopranos
about.
Lastly,
fucking whatever.
You're going to hate it.
People going to hate it.
It's a show called Selia.
Selia celly.
It's above Selia cruise.
The Cuban singer.
How do you spell it?
C E L I a what's it on?
It's on Netflix.
Somebody called me and said,
Joe,
you tube and no disrespect.
You should watch that show.
I W I knew Selia crews,
like my mom had the bar in the early
seventies.
My mom was tired,
that was Selia,
but I was going to Catholic school so
whenever she came by I wasn't there.
I would see her at the bar and I had
seen her a few times but I didn't know
much of what I like,
like three songs and Cuba.
She's like a folk lore like this fucking
like be people in Cuba.
What is she like a waste?
I watched this fucking show and I'm up
to episode 30.
Okay.
And they taped it like a Spanish
novella.
Right.
Which again,
nobody really liked it unless you grew
up on Spanish novellus,
but it fills you in on what was going
on.
Like she goes,
like right now,
Castro just took her fucking house.
So when you say she taped,
they taped like a Spanish novella.
You mean like Telemundo?
Novella.
But they made this into a TV show,
80 fucken episodes.
I'm up to 33,
80 episodes.
Eight episodes the first season.
I don't know what it is.
I just find somebody called me and turn
me onto it.
But it's not that interesting.
Like the singing is cool and I remember
growing up and listening to some of
those songs and my mom is ball.
What's going on as they break down the
gay thing in Cuba,
what I told you,
they used to take them shark island
thing and throw him off the boat.
Like this fucking kid was saying my
father left the house because I was gay.
Like it was so taboo when if you were
dark skinned,
like if you were any dark skin at all in
Cuba,
they would hate you.
Joe Rogen so when Castro got in there
and made it easier,
but Tiesta was robin people,
but Pisa was just a piece of shit.
I mean,
but these two were such a piece of shit
that 20 years after he was gone,
they were hunting down his soldiers in
the United States like fucking Nazi
soldiers.
Like they would get hunted down.
These groups of Cubans were hunting them
down and fucking beat them and shooting
them and shit.
That's how much.
Because it had become like it.
Towards the last five years of Cuba
become like,
if I pulled you over,
I just beat you,
fucked up.
Took your car and that was it.
But for eight years,
Cuba,
Fidel sat in those mountains.
It's like taken over La and sending up
and fucking San Francisco for eight
years waiting for the opportunity and it
breaks it down along the way how they.
It was easy for them to take home.
It was like stealing for.
They were waiting for fidelity to take
over the revolution.
It is pretty crazy.
He's still in control.
It's fucking crazy.
I mean this real,
you know,
and I knew this,
anybody like that out there now besides
him,
that,
that took a country by force and still
has control of it all these years later.
Oh,
he just wanted to people's houses and
said,
that's my,
you know,
this show doesn't touch on the casinos,
but he walked into the casinos and said,
go ahead,
call the mafia.
It's mine.
You show them.
They show the Cubans,
take him to all the American embassy
people.
What they do to them.
Just took him on the arm and walked into
the airport.
I have a nice life.
Wow.
You know,
they nationalized all the businesses.
It was just something that you don't
think about.
I don't think about it.
You know,
I'm,
I'm Americanized.
Whatever the fuck.
But it is the acting sensation.
It's just a little too much music.
Like you.
It's subtitles.
It's all Spanish.
When she,
you say that she was huge in Cuba.
Like all.
She was huge worldwide compared to
someone up today.
Like what would you compare it to when
they use this?
When used in 1956,
she had her first gold out.
Holy Shit.
That's a million,
right?
Yeah.
And now go is gold a 500,000
and a million and the people,
the owner of the company had to call the
fucking wreck.
Bandleader over and go,
we can't have this check though.
She's a darkie arc is don't sell records
in Cuba and that going to do it.
And he guaranteed them because you ever
talk like that.
I get a knock.
You the fuck out.
But if it goes gold,
you pay for the studio sessions.
If it doesn't go,
go,
let pam guarantee she became one of the
biggest actresses that actresses are not
the best looking fucking monster out
there.
I mean,
that was her argument also.
She was Haitian,
she was Cuban,
she was Haitian.
I don't know.
She probably had nation blood,
whatever the fuck it is,
but she was fucking Cuban.
But uh,
you know,
they said she wouldn't sell records
because she was ugly.
She wouldn't sell records because she
was dark skinned.
Like her actual music and the show.
Yeah.
And her singing and shit.
It's pretty fucking intense.
But it showed like three star goals for
her,
like she wasn't going to make it as a
fucking dark thing.
Uh,
you know,
they show like what Cuba was going
through,
like when Fidel fucking goes into a
house.
And now the last episode I watched you
supposed to go perform at the Tropicana
for the Common Dante,
you know,
and she's like,
he took my house,
now he wants me to go perform from
buckhead.
I'm not going down there,
but she's done that.
He's done that with Shay Guevara,
you know,
and all that shit.
So that's the last episode I watched.
That was it,
but check that out.
Episodes of that scares the shit out of
me now.
Joe Rogan,
that kind of time,
you'll watch two episodes in bail.
It's just,
it's kind of different.
It's different.
Even for me it was a little different at
first.
I,
I stuck with it because I grew up in it
and I kind of missed that.
Right now I don't have my parents.
I kind of missed that.
It's constantly in Spanish.
It's really good.
Cuban actors,
there's a couple Mexicans.
There's a couple fucking uh,
you know,
like light skin,
Mexico,
Julian.
We know that Mexicans to talked about
Cuba and the fifties.
What Cuba was in the fifties are you
like in Narcos?
I liked it.
I liked both seasons.
Pretty good.
Uh,
it was great.
I love that fucking show.
Did you get enough of that show?
Did you watch both seasons?
I haven't finished the second season
yet.
I'm halfway season.
Yeah.
I loved it.
Loved the first season.
I'm halfway into the second season,
but then I found stranger things and I
went off on a tangent and I had a watch
that I had to ride that motherfucker
right to the end.
I love that show.
There's a lot of good shows,
a lot of good shows out there.
West world,
Anthony Hopkins,
Ed Harris,
and Harris has always been a bad mother
fucker.
Fuck.
But this is is a piece Talese lazy
sauce.
This is the one.
This is the role where you know you're
going to see him a lot because you know
it's many,
many,
many episodes.
So it's like the.
The beautiful thing about game of
thrones is that it's a giant movie.
It's a movie that lasts many,
many,
many seasons and once you get used to
that,
a regular movies like it's not enough
time to tell a story 90 minutes and not
enough time to tell a story and you're
seeing that with shows like westworld
too.
It's like they're figuring out a totally
new thing and it totally new thing
being.
There's been shows before,
like last and a bunch of other shows
where there was a storyline they had to
follow through the entire,
you know,
all seasons and they all kind of
connected but not sort of the way
they're doing it now.
The way they're doing it now is with
nudity and swearing and violence and
sexuality and it's just,
it's all no holds barred.
I mean,
game of thrones is changed the whole
fucking game and now westworld is
changing the game too.
There's a bunch of these shows like that
that are just hbo and Netflix and you
know,
all these companies that have the budget
to put together essentially a movie a
week and they get these banging actors
and I'm telling you,
Ed Harris knocks it out of the park.
He's so creepy.
You believe a man,
you believe he's the boogeyman.
I keep.
If you were living in those wild west
days and Ed Harris Rides up in a fucking
horse outside your town with that creepy
fucking smile of his.
He can't even kill them.
Big Guns don't work on him.
Fuck man.
It's awesome.
Such a good show.
I didn't have enough.
Joey Diaz speaking.
A good show,
Jill.
We did is.
I heard you had a good show in Chicago
and I hope we're get hurt.
We're going to be to see that shit on
December eighth bitches.
You were a adzenys right?
The Rosemont Rosemont.
That's a great club.
Just a fun place club.
Uh,
Eddie Bravo said he saw you down there.
He said he had a great fucking time
Friday night.
We had a good time and then sadly the
first show was a little lumpy,
but the second show I just got out of
my,
you know,
I,
I was trying,
I was trying to be Jerry Seinfeld and I
had a script really for the first show.
Yeah.
I was going to stick this just because
it's a taping was the first time I had
the opportunity.
I was going to try to work a little
cleaner.
I didn't want them to.
I didn't want them to look at me and
say,
this guy,
you know,
I tell you why I'm a fan of MMA.
When I see growth,
I love when I watch it,
I'm in a fight.
When economy,
rego fought Nick Diaz the second time,
I was so happy that I finally,
somebody is doing what I'm talking
about.
You go back,
you look at your mistakes and you go
back to and correct them at the same
time.
You show up with a new weapon.
Don't keep telling me that you're the
hardest hitter in the UFC lightweight
division.
I don't want to hear that because it's
not about the hardest headed.
I don't want to hear that no more.
So I thought about my special from that
perspective and I go,
if I watch my special,
if I do come on the foot joke.
They're gonna know he never grew from.
They never really.
So I really wanted to try it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
but see that's they fuck with your head
band because those come in,
the foot jokes are great.
No,
I don't like them.
I just don't want to kill time and I'm
lazy,
but I just wanted to do something that
was me but not.
So I worked at that way,
the first ride tried to be Jerry
Seinfeld and it kind of worked a little
bit.
The technique was there,
but the old business wasn't.
Then I thought about the and I said,
fuck this.
I'm going to change this all up.
I'm going to go out this motherfucker
Capello.
So second fellow human that's been their
management order.
No order,
no nothing.
I Capello whatever the jokes.
I didn't want to use old jokes,
nothing like that.
It was all fresh stuff and it worked
out,
man.
I'm happy I did it 25 years.
It's done.
You know what we should do next?
It's going to take another one.
You know,
we should do next.
We should do like a Rodney dangerfield
special type thing with all of us with
like red and you and Duncan and put it
together and you know,
and do the same.
The way that Ronnie's still,
where they have like four or five comics
go on and do like 15 minutes,
you know,
you know sometimes that gets stuck with
comedy and I go back to those in my
world.
It was a great Kennison on their dice,
on their bill.
Hicks taught me an education because
fucking Andrew went up there and leveled
the room level level I would have ran
out of that.
Andrew dice clay and Bill Hicks went up
there with the composure,
slow them down with a cigarette,
smooth as a cucumber,
socked him in dark,
cool as a cucumber.
Suck them into a web of fucking are with
it.
Turned into something else.
A shop boy.
Schimmel destroyed that dom.
I rarer and Clark
and Clark droid it crushed always been
my go to when I'm fucking up with stand
up and Seinfeld Seinfeld fucked it up.
There was a couple of great people that.
Who else?
Robert Townsend.
Roseanne Barr?
Yeah.
Barry Sobel.
That's a leather jacket on,
right?
Barry Sobel.
Who went on to being punchline.
Yeah.
We really should do that.
Joey,
why don't we do that?
That should be our next thing.
Set it up.
Yeah,
we could do that.
and do it that way.
We could do another special quick,
like you do this special.
Then we can do another one in like seven
or eight months or something like that.
We'd all have 20 solid minutes at seven
or eight months.
We could throw on another show.
This is tremendous edibles.
Fuck No.
Why?
Because even if it don't get your high,
your breadth is fucking minty fresh.
After that.
It feels good and my mom tastes great
mind to.
So it's on Seeso and isn't there
something where you can sign up for
free?
Yeah,
I got a cold day.
I listened to the podcast and I give out
the CSO coding to get two free months.
I'll give it to you.
November 25th.
So you got until January as you get the
special fucking free.
Come on,
Joel Diaz.
Doug Stan hope is on.
That's right.
They're doing some other stuff too.
I've designed that.
Oh,
they shoot a ton of shit.
They're going to be the official comedy.
They want to go for it.
They want to go for it and they want,
well,
you know what,
I think these,
all these new networks are going to open
up the same way that Netflix has done.
It's going to.
It's obviously a very,
very good model and they're realizing
that now that's going to be the future.
It's these networks like CBS and NBC and
ABC.
Boy,
they're going to have a hard time in a
few years staying afloat.
Well,
let's think about it.
What's Netflix?
How much a month?
Nine bucks.
Three $99 for CSO.
CSO is only going to be a sports one.
That's going to be like $2.
Pretty soon you're going to be spending
$21 and you're going to get programming
from fucking Mars.
Yeah.
What does he have?
What's on it?
They have a small office.
It's an NBC thing.
NBC,
so they've got everything.
he was all 40 years Saturn,
live side that live and see all,
but I guess they will.
They're starting.
Yeah,
I guess they went after a lot of
comedians.
Specials is already doing this thing on
Seeso.
I'm not sure.
They have like original networking on
them,
like original programming network.
You know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
That's awesome.
It's tremendous.
Well I think that's the future.
The future is those.
I mean like Netflix didn't become
netflix overnight.
There was something I was watching
online with.
This guy was talking about big companies
and companies to look for and you know,
it was companies like Google and apple
and big technology companies.
Anything that Netflix is going to be one
of the next big technology companies.
You look at the growth and we'll get
what it's worth now and what it's
projected to be worth like in 2020 and
it's like it just keeps growing and
growing and as more and more people
abandoned cable like less and less
people are getting cable.
More and more people are getting their
TV from Netflix and you know,
the thing is the idea of watching
something.
You have to be home at 8:00
and going to be sitting there waiting.
It seems archaic.
It seems archaic to wait for a show.
And what Netflix also does to get you in
turn you into a junkie is they.
You could just binge.
He could just sit there and watch all
the narcos episodes.
Just sit there.
I'll come home with a knife.
We don't stand up to unwind the watching
an episode of fucking fuck.
Yeah.
I liked that.
Bestowed seven.
That's all.
That's been one of my favorite episodes
of television the last 20 years.
Episode Seven.
Law as Pinata.
I don't know what was when he kills the
two guys and puts them in the oven the
first season to the arts.
Who was driving the stealing from him
and Gada.
That was dark when he did that episode.
That's when I knew we were onto some
fucking.
His acting is fucking second to none
right now.
That duke is out act motherfuckers.
He's a skinny dude that walks fat.
I've never seen that.
What he put on a lot of weight for that
role,
that role.
I've never seen that shit.
Yeah,
you buy it.
You buy.
He who?
He,
you know,
he's pretending to be a good fucking
show.
There's a lot of good stuff out there
these days,
but Joey Diaz is on Seeso,
December eighth.
Motherfuckers.
What's it called when you calling it
sociably.
Unacceptable.
Sociably.
Socially or sociably?
I have no fucking idea what the
questions.
Just go.
The Cecil December right now.
Might change the title by that time.
So it's A.
Have you edited it all?
Yeah,
I got a couple of edits.
It looks fucking tremendous.
Beautiful.
Um,
so um,
when they put it up you can just stream
it live,
right?
It's just awesome.
And then again,
if you want to get on and get on it now
because Doug Stanhope is already on
Seeso and you can check out his thing to
Joey's is December eighth.
I'll definitely have you on before them.
We'll let her know for pops up and we're
doing new year's Eve motherfuckers.
Home of Ebi with Tony Golden Pony.
Hinchcliffe A.
I think it's almost sold out.
There was a very,
I think there less than 100 tickets left
as of this week.
So don't sleep.
You know,
I came up here to promote something,
but what is it on the way up here?
They were like,
Joey,
there's only 60 tickets.
I didn't know.
I thought that.
What is it,
the willow when you're doing the Wilbur
November 11th.
Oh Shit.
Well let them know if you're in Boston.
That's fucking theater is one of the
best theaters to see stand up because
it's three tiers and it's stacked right
in front of you.
So it's a big ass crowd,
but it feels like a small crowd because
each it's like there's three small
crowds that sort.
It's like it's like three,
300 seat comedy clubs stacked on top of
each other.
Places got foxwoods and even that night
was selling tickets.
I was like,
that let's just bail on it because it's
UFC.
See Two,
oh five.
Everybody's little watch UFC 205.
They're like,
no,
we're selling tickets.
I said,
okay,
well if people could stay off their
fucking phones and just hit that Dvr and
just la La la La la and not listened to
the radio is a drive home,
blah blah,
blah,
blah blah.
And then get in front of the TV.
They can watch it like as if it was a
live event.
So they could see you.
And then go watch the fights.
This motherfucker's all right folks.
That's it.
That's the end.
That's the end for this week.
I'm going out of town.
I got to go kill some deers with bows
and arrows.
See a deer.
No S and a be back soon.
Bye.
Love you guys.
Shit at it.